Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hi everybody, Dominic Sambrook from The Rest is History here. Now as you can probably tell from the noise of the pool, I am joined by friend of the show, Anthony Scaramucci, who is on his island surrounded by the luxurious trappings of wealthy, is of course the host of The Rest is Politics US and Anthony and I have a very special announcement. On Sunday the 30th of March, Anthony is over in the UK, and we have decided to do a live show together at the Theatre Royal Drury Lane in London.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，我是《历史的余烬》的多米尼克·桑布鲁克。正如大家可能从游泳池的噪音中听出的那样，今天和我在一起的是节目的老朋友安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇。他正待在自己的岛屿上，被财富的奢华生活所环绕。他当然也是《美国政治的余烬》的主持人，我和安东尼有一个非常特别的公告要宣布。3月30日星期日，安东尼将来到英国，我们决定在伦敦德鲁里莱恩皇家剧院共同举办一场现场演出。
Haven't we, Anthony? We have. You know, and thank God I'm not British, because the Brits actually admire my American Arrivista attitude about life, okay? But in any event, okay, it'd be the first time on stage with Dominic. I am very excited.
对吧，安东尼？没错。你知道的，感谢上帝我不是英国人，因为英国人其实很欣赏我那种对待生活的美国暴发户态度，好吧？但无论如何，这将是我第一次和多米尼克同台演出。我非常激动。
We're gonna be doing a show on US political history called The Rest is Assassinations, from Lincoln to JFK. But Dominic and I both know on the 30th of March, 2025, it's the 44th anniversary of the attempted assassination on Ronald Reagan. So there's not only assassinations here, which are terrible, but there's an attempted assassination, several of them, Dominic, right, throughout US history. And so we're excited to go through this and what the impacts were on American history and global history.
我们将做一个关于美国政治历史的节目，名为《暗杀的余烬：从林肯到肯尼迪》。但我和多米尼克都知道，在2025年3月30日，是罗纳德·里根遇刺未遂事件44周年。所以这里不仅有暗杀事件——这些事情很可怕，而且还有暗杀未遂事件，多米尼克，美国历史上发生过好几次，对吧？因此，我们很高兴能梳理这些事件，以及它们对美国历史和全球历史产生的影响。
Right. And there's so many great stories. So obviously JFK, you and I disagree about JFK because I of course think it was Lee Hovey Oswald acting alone and you think differently. But there are other stories. You mentioned attempted assassinations. So for example, FDR, FDR was almost shot before his inauguration in 1933. And that's an attempted assassination that really could have changed the course of history,
没错。而且这里面有那么多精彩的故事。所以很显然，关于肯尼迪，你和我意见不一，因为我当然认为是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德单干，而你的看法则不同。但还有其他故事。你提到了暗杀未遂。比如，罗斯福（FDR），罗斯福在1933年就职典礼前差点被枪杀。那是一场真正可能会改变历史进程的暗杀未遂，
because no FDR, does the United States still enter the Second World War? Does the story of the 20th century play out completely differently? So there was so much to talk about, and I'm really, really looking forward to doing it. What are you looking forward to most, Anthony? Well, I mean, all of that,
因为如果没有罗斯福，美国还会加入第二次世界大战吗？20世纪的历史走向会不会完全不同？所以有太多东西可以谈了，我真的非常非常期待。安东尼，你最期待的是什么？嗯，我是说，所有这些，
but I wanna delve into a little bit of the Secret Service and some of the men in that service. Clint Hill is still alive. He was riding alongside of Jackie and John Kennedy on the 22nd of November in 1963. And we'll talk about what he saw. We'll talk about what other agents have written about recently.
但我想要深入了解一下特勤局以及该局的一些特工。克林特·希尔（Clint Hill）现在还活着。在1963年11月22日那天，他曾骑车跟在杰奎琳和约翰·肯尼迪的身边。我们将谈谈他看到了什么。我们还会谈谈其他特工最近写了些什么。
And of course, now that Donald Trump is releasing the JFK assassination files, I think there'll be a lot to talk about there. The people coming to the show are going to learn things that have never been said or heard before. So the listeners, if you're not excited by that, I don't know what would excite you, frankly. So the good news is pre-sale tickets are available this Friday, the 21st of February from 10
当然，现在唐纳德·特朗普正在公布肯尼迪遇刺案的档案，我认为那里会有很多内容可谈。来到现场的观众将了解到以前从未被讲述或听到过的事情。所以听众朋友们，如果这都不能让你们兴奋，坦白说，我不知道还有什么能让你们兴奋了。所以好消息是，预售门票将于本周五，即2月21日上午10点开始发售，这是我们《历史的余烬》俱乐部会员的专属福利。您将在售票开始前收到包含链接的电子邮件；如果您还不是《历史的余烬》俱乐部会员，只需前往 therestishistory.com 注册，即可收到带有链接的电子邮件。本次活动的公开售票将于2月24日星期一英国时间上午10点面向公众开放。我们将在早晨向我们的邮件列表发送链接，并将其发布在《历史的余烬》和《美国政治的余烬》的社交媒体账号上。所以，如果你是一个热爱特殊关系的爱国英国人，如果你是一个住在伦敦的美国人，或者如果你是一个就是喜欢坐飞机跨越大西洋来观看
o'clock in the morning exclusively for our Rest is History club members. You will get an email with the link before the sale begins and if you're not a member of the Rest is History club just go to therestishistory.com to sign up and to get your email with the link. General sale for this event will be open to the public on Monday the 24th of February at 10 a.m. UK time. We'll send out the link to our mailing list in the morning as well as posting it on the rest is history and the rest is politics US's social media feeds. So if you're a patriotic Brit who loves the special relationship, if you're an American living in London, or if you're an American who just loves getting on planes across the Atlantic to see the
最高水平娱乐表演的美国人，我们绝对期待在3月30日星期日那天在西区见到你。说实话，我真正希望的是在演出当晚，安东尼能最终揭开肯尼迪遇刺案背后的真相。好吧，我可能会因为很多原因被关进关塔那摩，多米尼克，但那大概会排在第一位。不过无论如何，我们希望能在那里见到你。我想你会学到很多东西。我们将提供许多深刻的见解，并为美国、英国和全球历史提供极佳的背景信息。[《星条旗永不落》] 黑暗之心的深处，棕色的水流奔涌向前，带着我们向下游奔向大海，
very highest quality entertainment, we absolutely expect to see you there in the West End on Sunday, the 30th of March. And to tell you the truth, what I'm really hoping is that on the night, Anthony will finally reveal the truth behind the JFK assassination. Well, I'm probably going to Guantanamo for many reasons, Dominic, but that would be probably the top one. But anyway, we hope to see you there. I think you'll learn a lot. There'll be a lot of insight we'll provide and also provide great context on American and British and global history. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] The brown current ran swiftly out of the heart of darkness, bearing us down towards the sea
速度是我们逆流而上时的两倍。库尔茨的生命也在飞速流逝，从他的心头涌入无情时间的海洋。我从未见过任何接近他面部特征变化的景象，也希望永远不要再见到。哦，我没有被触动。我被迷住了。就好像面纱被撕裂了一样。在那张象牙般的脸上，我看到了阴郁的傲慢、无情的权力、
with twice the speed of our upward progress. And Kurtz's life was running swiftly too, ebbing out of his heart into the sea of inexorable time. Anything approaching the change that came over his features I have never seen before and hope never to see again. Oh, I wasn't touched. I was fascinated. It was as though a veil had been rent. I saw on that ivory face the expression of somber pride, of ruthless power,
卑怯的恐惧，以及一种强烈而绝望的绝望。在那完全清醒的至高时刻，他在对欲望、诱惑和屈服的每一个细节的回味中，重新度过了一生吗？他在某个意象、某个幻象前低声哭喊。他大叫了两声，那喊声微弱得如同一次呼吸。两次，那喊声微弱得如同一次呼吸。恐怖，恐怖。以上就是约瑟夫·康拉德的《黑暗的心》，最初于1899年发表在《布莱克伍德杂志》上，它不仅是英语世界中，也是有史以来最著名的中篇小说之一。我们虽然不是《文学的余烬》，但除了其无与伦比的文学价值之外，这本书在历史播客中也绝对值得一谈，原因正如我们在刚刚结束的关于比利时刚果的系列节目中一直提到的一样，因为正如图书馆里库尔茨临终时所说的那样，我们在那三集中讨论过的一切历史、
of craven terror, of an intense and hopeless despair. Did he live his life again in every detail of desire, temptation and surrender during that supreme moment of complete knowledge? He cried in a whisper at some image, at some vision. He cried out twice, a cry that was no more than a breath. twice, a cry that was no more than a breath. The horror, the horror. So that was Joseph Conrad, Heart of Darkness, first published in Blackwoods magazine in 1899, and one of the most celebrated novellas, not just in English, but full stop, ever written. We are not not the rest is literature, but this is a book that quite aside from its incredible literary value is also well worth doing in a history podcast for reasons that we have been touching on Dominic throughout the series that we've just finished about the Belgian Congo because at the heart of darkness is all the history,
所有的恐怖，都汇聚在黑暗的心中。绝对的，汤姆。是的。大家好。那么，康拉德的伟大长篇或中篇小说《黑暗的心》，其实掩盖了我们在刚果所做的系列节目。是的。
all the horror, as Kurtz might put it as he dies, that we have been talking about in those three episodes. Absolutely, Tom. Yes. Hi, everybody. So, Heart of Darkness, Conrad's great novel or novella, has kind of overshadowed the series that we've done in the Congress. Yeah.
如果不做一期节目来谈论它，那就太奇怪了，因为可以说它是过去120年左右创作的、最具影响力的文学作品之一。我们不是《文学的余烬》，但纯粹从文学意义、从一种纯粹的文学文化意义上来说，这是一本极其重要的书。它是文学现代主义的一个绝佳范例。它的散文非常具有梦幻色彩，就像幻觉一样。它非常夸张。其中有时空的转换，叙述者嵌套在叙述者之中。所有这一切带来的效果是，当你阅读它时——汤姆，这是一本很短的书，对吧？——你会全程感到不安。有一种焦虑感，而且它影响深远。因此，伟大的诗人T·S·艾略特非常喜欢康拉德的《黑暗的心》。
It would be weird not to have an episode talking about it because it's arguably one of the most influential works of literature written in the last 120 years or so. We are not the rest is literature, but purely in a literary sense, in a kind of purely literary cultural sense, it's an enormously important book. It's a brilliant example of literary modernism. The prose is very dreamlike, It's like a hallucination. It's very overwrought. There are shifts in time, narrators within the raters. And the effect of all this is when you're reading it, it's quite a short book, isn't it Tom? But you feel unsettled the whole time. There's a kind of sense of anxiety and it's very influential. So T.S. Eliot, he, the great poet, he loved Conrad's Heart of Darkness.
他有一首名为《空心人》的诗，开头引用了书中后文的一句话：“库尔茨先生——死了”。而你刚才在开头朗读的那段以那些名言“恐怖，恐怖”结尾的段落，他不是曾希望把它作为他那首伟大长诗《荒原》最初的题词吗？威廉·巴伦：我的意思是，《黑暗的心》最厉害的地方在于它极其适合被引用。我们在整个系列节目中一直在引用它，比如“恐怖，恐怖”、“库尔茨先生死了”。我是说，艾略特对精彩的妙语有着一种喜鹊般的敏锐眼光。所以，他会选中它一点也不令人惊奇。而且
He had a poem called The Hollow Men that begins with a quotation later on in the book, Mr. Kurtz, he dead. And that passage that you read at the beginning, ending with those famous words, the horror, the horror, he wanted that, didn't he, as his original epigraph for his great poem, The Wasteland? Will Barron Well, I mean, the thing about Heart of Darkness is it's incredibly quotable. We have been quoting it throughout this series and things like The Horror of the Horror of Mr. Kurtz, He Dead. I mean, Eliot, who has a kind of magpie eye for brilliant snatches of phrasing. I mean, it's not surprising that he would fix on it. And
我也在想，《荒原》是一首关于第一次世界大战的诗，如果你愿意这么看的话，那是欧洲文明内部显露出的黑暗之心。我认为在某种意义上，《黑暗的心》之所以拥有现在的地位，是因为它略微带有预言的性质，因为那个位于比利时刚果的黑暗之心，结果竟成了1914年吞噬欧洲的黑暗的预言。是的，汤姆，我完全同意你的看法，我认为这是一个非常好的观点。我认为你可以说，《黑暗的心》预示了20世纪关于人类作恶能力的许多文化评论，
I wonder also, The Wasteland is a poem about the First World War, if you like, the heart of darkness that had been revealed within European civilization. And I think that there is a sense in which one of the reasons that Heart of Darkness has the status it does is it has slightly has the quality of prophecy because that Heart of Darkness that is located in Belgian Congo turns out to have been a prophecy of the darkness that will engulf Europe in 1914. Yeah, I completely agree with you Tom, I think it's a really good point. I think you can argue the Heart of Darkness prefigures so much of the kind of cultural commentary of the 20th century about, and we'll get onto this in the second half,
你可以称之为“命运”。正是如此。凝视未来，看到等待着我们的恐怖。现在，如果你对文学完全不感兴趣，你可能会想：那又怎样，谁在乎呢？好吧，这里有一个很好的回答：《黑暗的心》可以说是西方帝国主义（特别是在非洲）最杰出的文化表现形式。
about man's capacity for evil. Fartic, you might call it. Exactly. Gazing into the future and seeing the horrors that await. Now if you're not interested in literature at all, you may be thinking, well, so what, who cares? I mean, here's a good answer to that. Heart of Darkness, I would argue, is by far the preeminent cultural representation
所以它是《所罗门王的宝藏》。我想现在是《黑暗的心》。所以我们曾经……我认为《黑暗的心》和《所罗门王的宝藏》可以说是截然相反的两极，对吧？是的，确实如此。《所罗门王的宝藏》是深入非洲腹地的冒险之旅，充满惊险刺激，最终是一个乐观的故事，是欢乐的，而且它认为，最终探险家有权呆在那里，从未对这一点提出过质疑。
of Western imperialism, particularly in Africa. So it's King Solomon's minds. I think it's heart of darkness now. So we did, we, I think heart of darkness and King Solomon's minds are kind of the polar opposites, aren't they? Yeah, they really are. King Solomon's minds is the journey into the heart of Africa that is swashbuckling, that is ultimately an optimistic story, that is jolly, that never questions, I think, ultimately,
而这是一次出了可怕差错的冒险。它讲述的正是这背后的阴暗面。而且事实是，你一直期待冒险类的主题介入，但它们从未真正出现，或者如果出现的话，也是以一种扭曲和产生幻觉的方式。把这两部作品作为对照来阅读，我认为，真的非常迷人。我完全同意。我完全同意。
the right of the adventurous to be there. This is an adventure that goes horribly wrong. And it's very much about the dark side of that. And also it's the fact that you keep expecting adventure type themes to kick in and they never quite do or if they do in a distorted and hallucinatory way. And to read them as a pairing I think is, I mean, really fascinating. I couldn't agree more. I couldn't agree more.
事实上，与《所罗门王的宝藏》不同，《黑暗的心》留下了巨大的文化足迹。所以从诸如《孤岛惊魂》系列这样的电子游戏（基本上取材于《黑暗的心》）到最著名的弗朗西斯·科波拉的电影《现代启示录》。该片于1979年上映，并将其背景转换到了越南战争。在《现代启示录》的拍摄过程中，甚至连拍片过程本身也变成了一种对《黑暗的心》的致敬，因为他们拍了一部关于这部电影拍摄过程的纪录片，名叫《黑暗之心》。而且正如人们所熟知的，弗朗西斯·科波拉在谈到《现代启示录》的拍摄时曾说：“我们拥有过多的资金、过多的设备，渐渐地我们发疯了。”是的，恐怖，恐怖。完全正确，完全正确。
And actually rather liking Solomon's Minds, Heart of Darkness has had a massive cultural footprint. So everything from video games like the Far cry series which basically riffs on how to don this to most famously frances coppers film apocalypse now. Which came out in nineteen seventy nine and transpose is it to vietnam war and apocalypse now even the making of it turned out to be a kind of riff on how to Darkness because they made a film about the making of it called Hearts of Darkness. And very famously, Francis Ford Coppola said about the making of Apocalypse Now, we had access to too much money, too much equipment, and little by little we went insane. Yeah, the horror, the horror. Absolutely, absolutely.
然后这本书还有第三个维度，我认为这让它变得非常有趣。那就是，在它出版后的最初几十年里，它被视为一本对帝国主义持强烈批判态度的书。它被视为对文明使命的伟大文学抨击。因为我的理解对吗？“帝国主义”这个词正是在康拉德写作这段时期开始进入日常用语的？完全正确。19世纪90年代、20世纪初是帝国主义论述（无论是支持还是反对）的最高峰。但现在到了21世纪，《黑暗的心》在很多评论家眼中不再被视为对帝国主义的攻击，
And then there's a third dimension, I think, of this book that makes it incredibly interesting. And that is that initially, in the first few decades after its publication, it was seen as a book that was very critical of imperialism. It was seen as the great literary assault on the civilizing mission. Because am I right that imperialism is a word that is coming into common use exactly at the time when Conrad is writing this? Exactly. 1890s, 1900s is the high point of the discourse as it were of imperialism, both pro and anti. But now in the 21st century, Heart of Darkness is seen not as an attack on imperialism by
而是被视为帝国主义的一个例证，一本本质上属于帝国主义且最重要的是非常种族主义的书。它可能已经成为象征对西方正典（你可以这么称呼它）的攻击，或者说象征对西方正典的批判的唯一一本书。所以，如果你对人们如何看待帝国主义、欧洲在世界上的地位、文学史、上个世纪的文化史有一点点兴趣，《黑暗的心》就处于许多这类辩论的中心，不是吗？因此，我们将在第二部分深入探讨许多这些问题。但在第一部分，
a lot of critics, but as an example of it as a book that is fundamentally imperialistic and above all, very racist. And it's probably the one book that has come to symbolize the attack on the Western canon, I suppose you might call it, or the criticism of the Western canon. So if you're at all interested in what people think about imperialism, Europe in the world, literary history, cultural history in the last century, Heart of Darkness is at the center of a lot of those kind of debates, isn't it? So we'll get into a lot of these issues, particularly in the second half. But in the first half,
我认为我们应该阐明两点。首先，约瑟夫·康拉德是谁？他到底在刚果做什么，从而激发了这本书的灵感？其次，对于不了解这本书的人来说，它到底讲的是什么？所以，非常非常快地、非常迅速地总结一下，如果你从未读过这本书，它讲述了一个名叫马洛的海员的故事。他乘蒸汽船逆刚果河而上，寻找一个公司的杰出特工——这家公司看起来像是一家特许公司——名叫库尔茨先生，
I think we should set out two things. The first of all is who is Joseph Conrad and what's he doing in the Congo at all to inspire this book? And secondly, what is the book about for people who don't know? So just very, very quickly, very swiftly to summarize, if you have never read the book, it's the story of a sea captain called Marlow. He takes a steamboat up the Congo and he's looking for a brilliant agent of the company of this what appears to be a concession company Called mr. Kurtz Who's a great ivory trader? He's up there in the interior and he seems to have lost his marbles and
他是一个伟大的象牙商人。他在内陆，而且他似乎精神错乱了，当马洛到达那里时，他发现各种各样的事情都在发生。是的，各种各样的事情都在发生。我们将剖析各种各样的事情都在发生。我们稍后会详细剖析。现在，有人问康拉德，这本书是关于什么的？他说：“《黑暗的心》是将经历稍微、仅仅非常稍微地推向超越案件实际事实的边缘。”换句话说，你真的想了解它是关于什么的吗？这是一个真实的故事。这是一个被夸大的真实故事。
When Marlow gets there he finds out that all kinds of stuff has been going on Yeah, all kinds of stuff has been going on will unpick All kinds of stuff has been going on. We'll unpick all that a bit later on. Now, Conrad was asked, what's the book about? And he said, heart of darkness is experience pushed a little and only very little beyond the actual facts of the case. In other words, you really want to understand what it's about. It's a, it's a true story. It's a, it's a true story exaggerated.
所以它是自传性质的，但它也是一个真实政治形势的写照。完全正确。而这种政治形势就是我们在前三集节目中一直在谈论的。完全正确。那么让我们从康拉德本人开始。他的名字其实不是——我的意思是，约瑟夫·康拉德的小说充满了各种镜厅和（你知道的）故事套故事。他的名字其实不叫约瑟夫·康拉德。他的名字叫约瑟夫·特奥多尔·康拉德·科热尼奥夫斯基，他于1857年出生于现乌克兰的一个波兰贵族家庭和一个贫困家庭。这是一个非常乡村化的世界，曾经
So it's autobiographical, but it's also a portrait of a real political situation. Exactly. And the political situation is what we've been talking about in the previous three episodes. Exactly. So let's start with Conrad himself. His name actually isn't, I mean, Joseph Conrad's fiction is full of kind of halls of mirrors and, you know, stories within stories. His name actually isn't Joseph Konrad. His name is Jozef Teodor Konrad Kozianowski and he was born to a Polish noble family and a impoverished family in what's now Ukraine in 1857. And this was a very rural world that had once
是波兰东部边境地区的一部分，现在已经被俄罗斯帝国吞噬了。他的母亲爱娃在他七岁时去世了。他的父亲拥有一个绝佳的名字——阿波罗，他是一位诗人。我喜欢这个名字。是的，还是一位波兰革命者。所以他是一个了不起的人，阿波罗·科热尼奥夫斯基。
been part of the eastern borderlands of Poland and has now been swallowed up by the Russian Empire. His mother Ava died when he was seven. His father, who had the brilliant name Apollo, who was a poet. I love that. Yeah. And a Polish revolutionary. So he's a tremendous man, Apollo Korzieniewski.
他在约瑟夫11岁时去世了。所以他是被亲戚抚养长大的。他在学校里感到非常无聊。显然，你知道的，他的状态不在最佳。他说他想去航海，他想去远方航海。因为显然，多米尼克，我读到过这在部分是因为他的父亲曾是一名政治犯。没错。
He died when Joseph was 11. So he's brought up by relatives. He's very bored at school. He's obviously, you know, he's not in the best of form. And he says he wants to go to see, he wants to go away to see. Because apparently Dominic, I read that this in part was because his father had been a kind of political prisoner. That's right.
正因如此，作为政治犯的儿子，他可能面临在俄罗斯军队中服役25年的兵役强制征召。是的。所以这也是他决定出国的原因之一。而且我想他最终具体去了马赛，对吧？而法国是这一时期波兰难民的巨大避难所。是的。现在，如果你想成为一名水手，你就会去法国，而马赛将是显而易见的地方。
And as such, as the son of a political prisoner, he was liable for a possible 25 year term of conscription into the Russian army. Yes. And so that's one of the reasons why he decides to go abroad. And I suppose he's specific, he ends up in Marseille, doesn't he? And France is the great refuge for Polish refugees in this period. Yes. Now, if you want to become a sailor, you go to France and Marseille would be the obvious place.
完全正确。所以1874年，他的亲戚们凑在一起，筹集了资金把他送到——他当时多大？16、17岁——把他送到马赛加入法国商船队。这是一件奇怪的事，他对自己开枪了。是的，他是打中了胸部，但这似乎有点像是一种表演行为。是的。我想他的小说里有很多这样的情节。我认为这绝对是对的。而且我认为他一直表现得非常……我认为“饱受困扰的人”这个词用得太重了，但是
Exactly. Exactly right. So in 1874, his relatives club together and they get together the money to send him to what is he 1617 to send him to Marseille to join the French merchant Marine. This is a weird thing that he shoots himself. Yeah, he's a chest, but it seems to have been a little bit performative. Yeah. As I guess so much is in his fiction. I think that's absolutely right. And I think he's come out as always a very, I think a troubled man is too strong, but
他是一个内心深处有着强烈感伤情绪的人，我想这种忧郁贯穿了他的一生。他在世界各地航行，去过加勒比海、南美洲，然后他的眼界开阔了。他加入了英国商船队，并在那里一直呆到1889年。他在世界各地经历了各种各样的冒险。他去过澳大利亚，去过曼谷，去过印度、新加坡，你可以看到很多这些经历反映在他的小说中，有许多关于南海探险的故事以及所有这些。
he is a man with a deep sense, a deep melancholy to him, I think throughout his life. He sails all over the world, Caribbean, South America, and then he goes up in the world. He joins the British merchant Marine and he stays there for until 1889. And he has all kinds of adventures all over the world. He goes to Australia. He goes to Bangkok he goes to India Singapore and you can see a lot of that reflected in his fiction lots of tales of Adventure in the South Seas and all of this Yeah
这就是他最奇特的地方，他在借鉴那些男童冒险小说、莱德·哈格德那种粗犷刺激的通俗小说的相同主题，然而它们总是比所有那些小说更加离奇、更加黑暗、更加充满幻觉。它们确实如此，完全没错。所以当他的书刚出版时，人们评论它们有点像是航海故事——你知道的，经典的航海故事，只是比平常更古怪一点。直到后来，人们才逐渐琢磨透他在做些什么。所以这个时候他还在使用科热尼奥夫斯基这个名字。
and this is the thing about him is that he is riffing on the same themes as kind of boys own adventurers as You know Ryder Haggard all this kind of ripping yarns and yet they're always stranger and darker and more hallucinatory than any of those. They are indeed exactly so there is something when his books first came out people reviewed them as kind of slightly sea stories you know classic tales of the sea but a bit weirder than usual and only over time did people kind of work out exactly what he was doing. So this point is still using the name Korzhonovsky.
英语是他的第三语言。我的意思是，这太神奇了。他在19世纪80年代末开始写作。他用英语写他的故事。但我的意思是，想象一下用你的第三语言写作。他，他在21岁之前似乎根本不会说英语。我的意思是，他能学得如此流利，以至于能写出英语散文中的一些杰作，这简直令人难以置信。虽然我
English is his third language. I mean, this is the amazing thing. He starts writing in the late 1880s. He writes his stories in English. But I mean, imagine writing in your third language. He, he seems not to have spoken English at all before he was 21. I mean, it's just unbelievable that he learns it so fluently that he can write some of the masterpieces of English prose. Although I
搜集到了一些资料，你看到福特·马多克斯·福特（Ford Madox Ford）对康拉德英语的评价了吗？“他的词汇绝对精确对应着含义，但他的重音极不准确，有时让人很难理解。”人们对我们也说过同样的话。我想特别是汤姆，老实说，他们是对你这么说的。我想偶尔也包括你。我承认也许，也许我比你更常见。汤姆说英语的腔调就像那是他的第三语言一样。但康拉德这个人，他非常内向。
gather, did you see the comment on Conrad's English by Ford Maddox Ford, his words absolutely exact as the meaning, but his accentuation so faulty that he was at times difficult to understand. People have said the same about us. I think specifically Tom, they've said it about you, to be fair. I think occasionally you as well. I accept maybe, maybe me more often than you. Tom who speaks English like it's his third language. But Conrad as a man, he's very reserved.
他非常敏感。他有一种贯穿他所做一切的深刻反讽感和怀疑精神。他对人性非常怀疑。在许多方面，他极其保守。事实上，在很多方面都相当反民主。当人们有时说，如果你倾向于极端反动，你就无法创造出伟大的艺术或伟大的文学时，我认为康拉德就是那种
He's very sensitive. He has this deep sense of irony and kind of skepticism that runs through everything he does. Very skeptical about human nature. He is intensely, in many ways, intensely conservative. Indeed, quite anti-democratic in many ways. When people sometimes say, you can't create great art or great literature, you know, if you're of a very reactionary disposition, I think Conrad is one of those people who
把这种观点彻底证伪的人。不管怎样，1889年在南海游荡了一番后，他回到伦敦，开始写他的第一部小说《阿尔迈的爵位》。然后，在1890年初，他第一次回到了他的故乡乌克兰。事情进展得并不顺利。他在那里时和家人相处得并不融洽。你可以想象，嗯，想象一下，他可能在脑海中把那里的情景想象得很完美。这非常令人失望，因为他相当冷漠，
probably proves that comprehensively wrong. Anyway, 1889 has been off in the South Seas. He comes back to London, he starts writing his first novel, Almey's Volley. Then at the beginning of 1890, he goes for the first time back to his homeland, Ukraine. And it doesn't go well. He doesn't get on with his family when they're there. You can imagine, well imagine, he's probably built it up in his mind about what it would be like. It's very disappointing because he's quite aloof
而且因为他有过所有这些离奇的经历，他显得有些格格不入。嗯，还有，他现在已经适应了船上的生活，不是吗？你会觉得他在……呃，是的，但我的意思是，他在陆地中央，四周被广袤的欧亚大陆所包围。他一定——你认为他渴望大海吗？我不知道，也许吧。我的意思是，他在陆地中央，四周被广袤的欧亚大陆环绕。他一定——你觉得他渴望大海吗？
and because he's had all these strange experiences, he doesn't quite fit. Well, also he's got sea legs now, hasn't he? You think he's wobbling all over the place in the... Well, yes, but I mean, he's in the middle, surrounded by land, surrounded by the great Eurasian land mass. He must, do you think he's got a yearning for the sea? I don't know, maybe I mean, he's in the middle surrounded by land, surrounded by the great Eurasian landmass. He must, do you think he's got a yearning for the sea?
我不知道。也许我太浪漫主义了。有可能。因为当他回来并且感到失望时，他做的第一件事就是出海。早在去乌克兰之前，他就曾与布鲁塞尔的一家公司、一家比利时航运公司谈过加入他们船队的事，而且他其实已经签了一份合同。现在这家公司，人们会想起我们关于
I don't know. Maybe I'm being over romantic. Possibly. Because when he gets back and it's disappointing, the first thing he does is to go to sea. Now before he'd gone to Ukraine, he'd been talking to a company in Brussels, a Belgian shipping firm about joining one of their ships and he's actually already signed a contract. Now this company, people we reminded of all these companies from the episode we did about
E·D·莫雷的那集节目中所有的这些公司，所有那些拥有特许权和合同的轮船公司。这家公司叫做“安特卫普-上刚果商业比利时匿名公司”（Société Anonyme Belge pour le Commerce du Haut Congo）。所以它负责处理来自上刚果的商业贸易，是一年前成立的，旨在从内陆出口象牙和橡胶。所以它运营着一条轮船航线，并拥有一系列自己的贸易站。为什么康拉德要与这家公司签约？很显然，原因之一是他需要钱。他实际上（你知道的）是一个雇佣兵。
E.D. Morrell, all these steamship companies with concessions and contracts. This company is called the Société Anonyme Belge pour le Commerce du Haut Congo. So it's handling the commerce from the upper Congo and it had been founded a year earlier to export ivory and rubber from the interior. So it runs a steamer service and it has a series of trading stations of its own. And why does Conrad sign up with this company? Well, obviously one reason is he needs the money. He's effectively, you know, a mercenary.
他会为了钱去世界各地进行各种航行。你知道的，雇佣兵嘛，他会为了钱去世界各地进行各种各样的航行。但正如他的伟大传记作家齐兹斯瓦夫·奈达（Zdzisław Najder）——一个波兰人，他的书绝对是……很难买到。这是你的第三语言吗，波兰语？是的，完全正确。完全正确，汤姆。发音相当流利。是的，谢谢。
He will take the money to go on various voyages all over the world. know, a mercenary, he will take the money to go on various voyages all over the world. But as his great biographer, Zdryswof Nida, who's a Pole, his book is absolutely, it's quite hard to get hold of. Is this your third language, Polish? Yeah, exactly. Exactly, Tom. Fluent pronunciation there. Yeah, thank you.
这可不是我准备了好几个小时的结果。奈达指出，康拉德一直梦想着非洲。作为一个在乌克兰长大的男孩，大约九岁时，他在地图上指着一块当时还是一片空白的区域说：“等我长大了，我想去那里。”现在他把这句台词给了马洛，对吧？在《黑暗的心》中。而且我们没有理由怀疑康拉德自己也是这么想的。
It's not like I've been preparing for hours. Nida points out that Konrad had always dreamed of Africa. As a boy in Ukraine, aged about nine, he had pointed his finger at a map where there was a blank space as there was in those days. And he had said, when I grow up, I'd like to go there. Now he gives that line to Marlow, doesn't he? In the Heart of Darkness. And there's no reason to doubt that Conrad himself thought like that.
无论如何，顺便说一句，也没有理由相信他怀疑文明的使命，因为他当时在写给他叔叔的信中确实谈到了这一点。无论如何，1890年5月10日，他登上了SS Ville de Marseille-aux-Aubordeaux号船，开始了这次被他的传记作家奈达称为他一生中最具创伤性的旅程。他们沿着非洲海岸南下，甚至在他们到达刚果之前，就有一个乘客对他说：“你要去刚果？那绝对是一场噩梦。”这不是你想听到的，对吧？是的。
Anyway, there's also no reason to believe, by the way, that he doubts the civilizing mission because he actually writes about this and lets us to his uncle at the same time. Anyway, May 1890, the 10th of May, he boards the ship, the SS Ville de Massey-aux-Aubordeaux, for this journey that his biographer Nida says is the most traumatic journey of his life. They go off down the coast of Africa, even before they get to the Congo, one passenger says to him, you're going to the Congo. That's an absolute nightmare. That's not what you want to hear, is it? Yeah.
他基本上说，所有去那里的人，要么死了，要么提前回家，因为那里太可怕了。而康拉德实际上说过——我引用原话：“我是一个穿着英国柏油雨衣的波兰贵族。”还有比这更酷的吗？不，这绝对是你所能成为的最好状态。总之，大约一个月后，他们到达了刚果自由国的首都博马。这里距离内陆只有50英里。在这里，如果人们还记得前几集的节目，就会知道你必须通过各种复杂的方式
He says basically everybody who goes there, they either die or they come home early because it's so terrible. And Conrad actually says, and I quote, I'm a Polish nobleman cased in British tar. Does it get better than that? No, that's the best thing you can possibly be. So anyway, about a month later, they reach the capital of the Congo Free State, Boma. So it's just 50 miles inland. And here, if people remember from the previous episodes, there's the various complicated
沿河逆流而上。因为急流和所有那些乱七八糟的事。所以他乘轮船逆流而上到达马塔迪，而马塔迪是急流之前你必须下船的最后一站。现在在马塔迪，他遇到了我们在周一谈过的人。这个人就是我们将在下周的加更节目中听到由约翰·班维尔（John Banville）讲述的人物，他就是罗杰·卡斯门特（Roger Casement）。
ways you have to move up the river. Because of the rapids and all that Malaki. So he gets a steamer up river to Matadi and Matadi is the last point before the rapids where you have to get off. Now at Matadi, he meets somebody that we talked about on Monday. And this is somebody who we're going to be hearing about from John Banville in next week's bonus episode. And this is Roger Casement.
——由约翰·班维尔在下周的加更节目中讲述，这就是罗杰·卡斯门特。所以这位英国领事，伟大的爱尔兰爱国者，一个了不起的人物。康拉德真的很喜欢卡斯门特，对吧？他说很高兴能遇到他。他认为他谈吐得体、极其聪明而且非常富有同情心。而且有很多传言说，你发现康拉德谈到过康拉德与卡斯门特以及他们所做的事情。康拉德本人似乎记错了他们做过的事。他说：“我们曾同住一个房间。”
about from John Banville in next week's bonus episode, and this is Roger Casement. So the British Consul, great Irish Patriots, an amazing character. And Conrad really took to Casement, didn't he? He said it's a great pleasure to have met him. He thinks, speaks well, most intelligent and very sympathetic. And there's a lot of talk that you find that Conrad, about Conrad and Casement and what they did. Conrad himself seems to have misremembered what they did. He said, we shared a room together.
他们毫无疑问没有住在一起，因为卡斯门特在很多时间里都不在那里。但他们确实花了很多时间在一起，并且可能一起去过一些当地的村庄，寻找搬运工和其他人来搬运康拉德的所有行李。所以我想正是在这个时候，康拉德开始看到我们在前几集中引用过的一些可怕场景。比如，汤姆，你读过那段关于六个头上顶着土筐的家伙的段落。你想提醒我们一下吗？
They undoubtedly didn't because Casement wasn't there for a lot of the time. But they definitely spent a lot of time together and they probably made trips together to see some of the local villages, to find porters and things to carry all Conrad's stuff. So I think it's probably at this point that Conrad starts to see that some of the terrible scenes that we've quoted in the previous episodes. So for example, Tom, you read that passage about the six blokes with baskets of earth on their heads. Do you want to remind us of that?
关于那些恐怖的场景？是的。所以“我能看到每一根肋骨，他们四肢的关节就像绳结一样，每个人的脖子上都戴着一个铁领圈，所有人都在用一条铁链连在一起，铁链的下垂部分在他们之间有节奏地叮当作响”，然后来到树林里，看到那里有人在死去，“黑色的身形，疾病和饥饿的黑色阴影混乱地躺在绿阴中”。当然，利奥波德为这种实际上属于奴隶劳动的行为给出的辩护是，这是进步的奴隶劳动，它将使得引入
Some of the horror? Yeah. So I could see every rib, the joints of their limbs were like knots in a rope, each had an iron collar on his neck and all were connected together with a chain whose bite swung between them rhythmically clanking and then comes to a grove and sees people there dying, black shapes, black shadows of disease and starvation lying confusedly in the greenish gloom. And of course, the justification that Leopold is giving for this effectively slave labour is that it's progressive slave labour, that it will enable the introduction
西方技术、蒸汽火车等成为可能，然后这将减轻搬运工的负担。但在《黑暗的心》中，对此有一种非常具有讽刺意味的转折，因为当马洛到达急流顶部等待他的轮船时，他发现轮船已经沉了，他不得不把它打捞上来，而且他们没有能把它组装起来的零件。是的。铆钉。铆钉。
of Western technology, steam trains, all of that, and then it will ease the burden on the porters. But there's a kind of very ironic spin on this in Heart of Darkness because when Marlowe gets to the top of the rapids wait to look for his steamer, he finds that it's been sunk and he has to dredge it up and they haven't got the bit, the bolts that would enable it to be put together. Yeah. Rivets. The rivets.
你会有一种感觉，甚至连他们声称的某种技术优势也是一种伪装。是的，绝对的。绝对的。康拉德是怎么说的？他在书中的某个地方说，当他向《布莱克伍德》杂志推销这本书时，他说这是对非洲那种效率低下和无能的表现的写照。这就像是在英国坐火车一样。没错，他坐的是公交车。这就是他坐的车。
You have the sense of even the claims to kind of technological superiority are a kind of sham. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. I mean, what does comrade say? He said at one point his book was when he's pitching it to Blackwoods He said it was a portrait of inefficiency and incompetence in there in Africa. It's like getting a train in Britain So right he's on a realm of placement bus. That's what he's on
所以他在卡斯门特那里闲逛了几个星期，然后他们找好了搬运工，准备从马塔迪开始进行陆上跋涉。他在用他的第三语言——英语写日记，这让你对当时的经历有了一些概念：夜里蚊子很多，月亮升起时听到远处村庄的叫喊声和击鼓声，度过了一个糟糕的夜晚，没有水，在一个泥泞小溪旁边的暴露山坡上露营。没有遮阳帐篷，斜坡上太阳火辣辣的，痛苦不堪，夜晚冷得悲惨，无法入睡，蚊子。他们继续前进，在某个地方他绝对经过了一具绑在柱子上的骷髅，这是一个非常——我的意思是，想象一下当你看到那个时——
So he's hangs around with Kacen for a couple of weeks and then they've got the porters and he's ready to start overland from Matadi and he wrote a diary in English in his third language, which gives you some sense of what it was like. Mosquitoes at night when the moon rose heard shouts and drumming in distant villages past a bad night, no water camped on an exposed hillside near a muddy creek. No shade tent on a slope, sun heavy, wretched, night miserably cold, no sleep, mosquitoes. And on they go, and at one point he definitely passes a skeleton tied to a post, which is a very- I mean, imagine seeing that when you-
是的，这是一个迹象，你知道的，记住，康拉德的阅历非常非常丰富。当然，不得不承认，他大部分的旅行都是在海上。所以他并不经常去他所访问过的地方的内陆。这太有趣了，不是吗？因为我们之前谈到过，对于欧洲人来说，一开始非洲全在于海岸，他们不深入内陆，那似乎是在浪费精力。
Yeah. So that's a sign, you know, remember, Conrad is very, very, very well traveled. I mean, admittedly, most of his travels have been at sea. So he hasn't often gone inland in the places he's visited. That's so interesting, isn't it? Because we talked earlier about how to begin with for Europeans, Africa is all about the coast, that they didn't go inland, that they just seemed a waste of effort. about the coast, that they didn't go inland, that it just seemed a waste of effort. And perhaps in that sense, Conrad is kind of emblematic of the transition that European
也许在某种意义上，康拉德可以说是欧洲冒险家从将非洲体验局限于海岸并深入内陆这一转变的象征。他正把那段完整的历史压缩到他个人身上。是的，我认为这是一个公正的观点。他越深入内陆，暴力对他就越明显。也许这种暴力在海岸上你看不到同样的程度，很难说。所以在某个地方，他看到一个政府官员在殴打搬运工，用棍子抽打，雨下得很大，他阻止了。换句话说，他进行了干预，把他们拉开了。
adventurers make from experiencing Africa as along the coasts and going inland. He's kind of compressing that entire history into his own person. Yeah, I think that's a fair point. And the deeper he goes inland, the more the violence becomes apparent to him. Perhaps violence that you don't see to the same extent on the coast, it's hard to say. So at one point he sees a government official beating porters, blows with sticks, raining hard, stopped it. In other words, he intervenes to break it up.
8月2日，他抵达了利普维尔（Leopoldville，现为金沙萨，刚果民主共和国首都）。在那里，正如你在小说中提到的，他原本要坐的轮船受损了。所以他不得不转乘另一艘轮船，这艘船带着极具讽刺意味的名字叫“比利时华号”（Hua de Belge）。你经常读到他是船长。他不是船长。有一个叫科赫（Koch）的丹麦人是船长，而康拉德将担任二副。从他的通信中我们知道，他已经幻灭了，因为他的叔叔塔德乌什（Tadeusz）此时写信给他，说：“不要撕毁合同。你会失去所有的钱，并且会在公司里落得个不可靠的坏名声。”
The 2nd of August he arrives at Leopoldville, now Kinshasa, the capital of the Democratic Republic of Congo. And there, as you mentioned in the novel, his proposed steamer has been damaged. So he has to transfer to another steamer, which is called, with sublime irony, the Hua de Belge. You often read that he's the captain. He's not the captain. There's a guy called Koch, a Dane, who is the captain, and Conrad is going to be the number two. And we know from his correspondence, he's already disillusioned because his uncle Tadeusz writes to him at this point and says, don't walk out on the contracts. You'll lose all your money and you'll get a bad reputation among the companies as somebody who can't be relied upon.
所以他显然一直在写信回国说：“我在，这太可怕了。我实际上在考虑撕毁合同”，而他的传记作家认为，这可能是因为他和公司的一位经理闹翻了，而他将不得不让这位经理搭便船。所以他一直和这位经理同行，公司的这位经理是一个名叫卡米尔·德尔科穆纳（Camille Delcommune）的比利时人，他真的存在于《黑暗的心》中，因为小说中的公司经理就是直接以这个叫德尔科穆纳的家伙为原型的。
So he's clearly been writing home and saying, I'm at, this is terrible. I'm actually thinking of breaking my contract and his biographers think. This is probably because he's fallen out with a company manager who he's going to have to give a lift to. So he's been traveling with him and the company manager is a Belgian called Camille Delcommune and he really is in heart of darkness because there's the company manager in heart of darkness who is modeled directly on this bloke del commune.
而且他与库尔茨的关系以及他对库尔茨的计划是一种扭曲，不是吗？完全正确。于是他们继续逆流而上，他们走得非常快，一个月内就行驶了一千英里。我的意思是，这些轮船可不是闹着玩的，船上有科赫船长、康拉德、一名来自比利时的机械师、25名非洲船员、德尔科穆纳以及其他三名公司特工。从商人的账目中我们知道，逆流而上的航程非常孤独。你遇不到多少其他船只。乡村荒凉，村庄被烧毁，人们躲在丛林里，遭受着“公共武力”（Force Publique）的蹂躏。
And whose relationship to Kurtz and his plans for Kurtz is kind of twist isn't that? Exactly. So on they go up river, they go very quickly, they're covering a thousand miles in a month. I mean these don't mess around these steamers and on board the ship there's Captain Koch, there's Conrad, there's a mechanic from Belgium, there are 25 African crewmen, Del Commune and three other company agents. And we know from traders accounts that the passage up river it's very lonely. You don't pass many other ships. The countryside is desolate, there are burned out villages, the people are hiding in the bush, depredations of the force public. And
正如齐兹斯瓦夫·奈达在他的传记中所说，《黑暗的心》的氛围显然是由这种压抑的、幽闭恐惧症式的孤立感所激发出来的——康拉德坐在逆流而上的船上，面对着死一般的寂静和空旷，一定感受到了这种感觉。我们之前提到过这一点，这让人联想到《失落的世界》以及所有那些人们回到史前过去的小说和电影，那种在某种源自丛林的巨兽突然冲出来的可怕揭示之前的寂静与荒凉感。我的意思是，《黑暗的心》要复杂得多，但确实有一种感觉：某种恐怖、某种惊骇正在等待着。
so as Zizewsow Nida says in his biography, the atmosphere of Heart of Darkness clearly is inspired by this kind of oppressive, claustrophobic isolation that Conrad must have felt on this boat going upriver with just the silence and the emptiness. We mentioned this before, but there are kind of prefigurings of the lost world and all those novels and then films where people go back into a prehistoric past and the sense of silence and desolation proceeding some appalling revelation of some saurian bursting out of the jungle or something. I mean Heart of Darkness is much more sophisticated than that but there is, you sense some terror, some horror is waiting.
绝对是的，绝对是的。因此，在9月1日，他们到达了河上最后一个可通航的点。这就是当时被称为斯坦利瀑布的地方。现在它被称为基桑加尼。这基本上已经是中非的心脏地带了。康拉德后来写道：“我满怀敬畏地对自己说，这就是我小时候夸下海口的地方。少男时代白日梦中那些理想化的现实，竟以这种结局收场。”所以这就是他多年前在地图上指出的那个点。
Definitely do, definitely. So on the first of September they get to the last navigable point on the river. This is what's then called Stanley Falls. Now it's called Kizangani. And this is basically now in the heart of Central Africa. And Conrad wrote later, I said to myself with awe, this is the very spot of my boyish boast. What an end to the idealized realities of a boy's daydreams. So this is the point that he pointed to on the map all those years ago.
而他到了那里，那种感觉不仅是粉碎性的失望，不仅如此，我敢说，还有他所看到的景象带来的恐怖。就像马斯克登陆火星一样。说实话，这不是我所期望的比较。好吧，他们在那里，在斯坦利瀑布呆了大约一周，他们接上了当地的代理人，一个叫克莱因（Klein）的法国人，乔治-安托万·克莱因（Georges-Antoine Klein）。他二十多岁。我们对他的了解非常少。
And he's got there and the sense of not just crushing disappointment, but more than that, dare I say the horror of what he has seen. Like Musk arriving in Mars. That wasn't a comparison I expected to be honest. Right, they stay there, Stanley falls for about a week, and they pick up the local agent, who's a guy called Klein, a Frenchman, Georges-Antoine Klein. He's in his late 20s. We know very little about him.
他得了严重的痢疾，他们决定：“好吧，我们要把这个叫克莱因的家伙带回去。”于是他们掉头返程。现在，克莱因在回程中去世了。他在几周后去世了，他的故事显然在某种程度上成为了《黑暗的心》中库尔茨故事的原型，当康拉德最初（你知道的）坐下来开始写这本书时，主角的名字就叫克莱因。但除此之外，它们之间再没有什么别的联系了。
He had terrible dysentery, and they decide, well, we're going to take this guy Klein back. So then they turn back. Now Klein died on the return journey. He died after a couple of weeks and his story is clearly the model in some way for the story of Kurtz and Kurtz when Conrad first, you know, sat down and started writing the book, he was called Klein. But apart from that, there is nothing to connect them.
他得了严重的痢疾，他们决定，好吧，我们要把这个叫克莱因的家伙带回去。于是他们折返了。结果克莱因在回程中死了。他在几周后去世了，他的故事显然在某种程度上成了库尔茨故事的原型，当康拉德最初坐下来开始写这本书时，库尔茨的名字就叫克莱因。但除此之外，它们之间没有任何联系。
There's no sense that this guy, Klein, was a madman, a bad guy, a guy who'd stared into the depths of the human soul. He's just a French bloke who's got terrible dysentery. But here is the sort of the germ of the idea of Mr. Kurtz, I guess. Anyway, they get back to Kinshasa after about three weeks. And here, Konrad writes to a friend of his back in Belgium called Marguerite Porodowska. And he says to her, I've actually now got terrible dysentery and fever. And I'm incredibly miserable. He says, I regret having come here.
没有迹象表明这个叫克莱因（Klein）的家伙是个疯子、坏蛋，或者是一个窥探过人类灵魂深渊的人。他只是一个得了严重痢疾的法国佬。不过我想，库尔茨先生这个形象的萌芽大概就是从这里来的。不管怎样，大约三周后他们回到了金沙萨。就在这里，康拉德给他远在比利时的朋友玛格丽特·波罗多夫斯卡（Marguerite Porodowska）写了信。他在信中对她说，其实我现在得了严重的痢疾和发烧。我痛苦得难以置信。他说，我很后悔来这里。
I regret it bitterly. I find everything repugnant. Especially, he says, the people. and he's talking about the Europeans and I am repugnant to them too from the director in Africa who has taken the trouble of telling a good many people of his intense dislike of me down to the lowest mechanic. Basically everybody hates me. Now the interesting thing is he never mentions the Congo itself and the violence in the Congo is a reason for his unhappiness.
我懊悔莫及。我对一切都感到厌恶。他特别提到，是人。而他说的“人”是指欧洲人，我对他们来说也很令人厌恶，从那个在非洲的局长——他特意告诉很多人他对我的极度反感——一直到最底层的机械师。基本上所有人都讨厌我。现在有趣的是，他从未把刚果本身以及刚果的暴力作为他不快乐的原因。
And do you think that's he's burying it? Well possibly because Sir Jusrof Nida says in his book and I think this does make sense. He says it's clear he thinks that Conrad had basically failed to hide how unhappy and how shocked he was with what he could see and that the, the other people, the, they'll commune, the other agents saw that and took against him. It was kind of lily livid liberal. Yeah. That he basically is spoiling their fun and he's judging them.
你认为他是在刻意掩盖吗？很有可能，因为西茹罗夫·尼达（Sir Jusrof Nida）在他的书中说过，而且我认为这确实说得通。他说，很明显，他认为康拉德基本上没能藏住他对所见之事的痛苦和震惊，而其他人，那些人，公社的人、其他特工都看出来了，并对他产生了反感。那是一种冷嘲热讽的自由主义。是的。基本上就是他扫了他们的兴，而且他在评判他们。
And you can see therefore it would sort of make sense that they would find him repugnant because he says he's a walking rebuke to their project. So he's definitely ill for the next few weeks. Um, and then he vanishes. So Conrad vanished at the paper trail disappears and he vanishes from sight. As Nida puts it, the image becomes confused, blurred, obscure, which is actually very appropriate given the way Conrad writes and actually the next time we come across him, he's back.
因此你可以理解，他们为什么会觉得他令人厌恶了，因为他说他是他们宏图大业的活生生的斥责。所以接下来的几个星期里，他无疑是病了；嗯，然后他就消失了。因此康拉德消失了，纸面记录断了，他从人们的视野中消失了。正如尼达所说，画面变得混乱、模糊、晦涩，鉴于康拉德的写作风格，这其实非常贴切；而我们下一次遇到他时，他已经回来了。
He's in Brussels in January 1891 and then next time we see him after that, he's in London. In February, there's no diary entries, there are no letters, there is nothing. And it's as though I think whatever has happened in those last days or weeks in the Congo, he wants to forget it, you know, whatever it is. So it's a kind of epistolary heart of darkness. It is indeed. You know, we don't know.
他在1891年1月回到了布鲁塞尔，再下一次见到他时，他已经在伦敦了。2月份没有日记条目，没有信件，什么都没有。这就好像我觉得，不管刚果最后那几天或几周发生了什么，他都想把它忘掉，你知道，不管那是什么。所以这是一种书信体的《黑暗的心》。确实如此。你知道，我们不得而知。
And I think it's plausible that it's during those last weeks that he really reaches his verdict on the Congo Free State. Yeah. When he attains what he called the distasteful knowledge of the vilest scramble for loot that ever disfigured the history of human conscience and geographical exploration. And there are sort of fragments in later letters and whatnot that give a sense of what he thought. So in 1903, just a few years later, he told his friend Cunningham Graham, a founder of
我认为这很合乎情理：正是在最后那几周里，他对刚果自由邦真正下达了判决。是的。当他获得了他所谓的“人类良心和地理勘探史上遭到玷污的最卑劣的争夺战利品中令人厌恶的知识”时。后来的书信中保留了一些片段之类的，让人能感知到他的想法。所以在1903年，也就是短短几年后，他告诉他的朋友Cunningham Graham，他是……的创始人之一。
Tom of the Scottish National Party, so a man with whom you'd have a lot to talk about. He said to Cunningham Graham that Leopold and his Free State agents were, and I quote, a gigantic and obscene beast. So that's fascinating, isn't it? Because again, we're talking about this idea of going into a prehistoric landscape. That is the beast. That is the beast. And he actually ends a letter to Cunningham Graham saying, you know, if you want to find
苏格兰国民党，所以这是一个和你有很多共同语言的人。他告诉Cunningham Graham，利奥波德和他的自由邦特工是——我引用原话——“一个庞大而淫秽的野兽”。这不是很迷人吗？因为我们再次讨论了进入史前景观这个概念。这就是那头野兽。这就是那头野兽。他在写给Cunningham Graham的信的末尾实际上写道，你知道，如果你想了解
out about this, you should talk to my mate Roger Casement. He could tell you things, things I've tried to forget, things I never did know. You know, there's this kind of sense of like the stuff at the periphery of his vision, half glimpsed, half understood that's going on. And he doesn't really want to think about it because it's so terrible. And I know we'll come to this, but there is something kind of the Freudian idea of a repressed memory, a darkness that even if you try and repress it, it is kind of bleeding out into your your dreams and your your fantasies.
这背后的真相，你应该去问问我的老友罗杰·卡斯门特（Roger Casement）。他能告诉你一些事，那些我试图忘记的事，那些我甚至从不知道的事。你知道，有这样一种感觉：在他视野的边缘，那些隐约闪现、半懂不懂的事情正在发生。他其实不想去想它，因为它太可怕了。我知道我们接下来会讲到这一点，但这里确实有一种弗洛伊德式的“被压抑的记忆”的概念——一种黑暗，哪怕你试图去压抑它，它也会渗入你的梦境和幻想中。
Absolutely, and the book absolutely has that flavour. So for the next three years, Conrad goes back to the merchant marine, he sails around, and then in 1894, he retires from the sea and he devotes himself to writing. And he writes a couple of novels, and he writes lots of stories and magazines like Blackwoods and the Strand, famously where Sherlock Holmes started. And in the middle of December, 1898,
绝对是这样，这本书完全带有这种风味。因此，在接下来的三年里，康拉德回到了商船队，四处航海；然后到了1894年，他退出了航海界，全身心投入到写作中。他写了几部小说，并在《布莱克伍德》（Blackwoods）和《斯特兰德》（The Strand，福尔摩斯正是在那里发迹的著名杂志）等杂志上写了大量故事。在1898年12月中旬，
he starts his third piece for Blackwoods magazine. And he says to the publisher, it's a narrative about a bloke who's on a river in central Africa. I'm thinking of Cornead, the heart of darkness, but the narrative is not at all gloomy. Which is clearly, I mean, that's not true. And he's, he obviously doesn't want the publisher to say, yeah, not for us mates. Yeah. It's like us with the trying to persuade him to do an episode. It's really upbeat and jolly and people will love it. Full of fun. And Comrade says to
他开始为《布莱克伍德杂志》撰写第三篇作品。他对出版商说，这是一个关于一个家伙在中非的一条河上的叙事。我在考虑《科涅德》（Cornead），《黑暗的心》，但这个叙事一点也不阴暗。这显然……我的意思是，这不是真的。显然他不想让出版商说：“好吧，老兄，这不适合我们。”这就像我们试图说服他做一期节目一样。这真的非常积极向上、欢乐，人们会大爱特爱。充满了乐趣。然后康拉德对
him, the theme is the criminality of inefficiency and pure selfishness when tackling civilizing work in Africa. Now, interestingly, this is Conrad's own thing. He's not been inspired by E.D. Morel's campaign or anything like that because that hasn't even started yet. Hasn't begun, has it? No, nowhere near. So it's obviously something that he feels he has to do or wants to do. And it's presumably the time where everyone still thinks it's brilliant and it's civilizing and hooray. Exactly. Now the most shocking thing for people like us, Tom, is how much Conrad is being paid. Blackwood's paid him £60 for this. So in relative income terms, that's about almost £50,000 today, which is a sign of how well this kind of writing was paid back
他说，这个主题是在非洲从事文明化工作时，无能和纯粹自私的犯罪性。现在有趣的是，这是康拉德自己的东西。他并没有受到E.D.莫雷（E.D. Morel）的运动或其他类似事情的启发，因为那甚至都还没有开始呢。还没开始，对吧？不，差得远呢。所以这显然是他觉得他必须做或者想要做的事情。而且这大概是每个人都还觉得它很棒、很文明、万岁万岁的时期。完全正确。现在，对我们这样的人来说，最令人震惊的事情，汤姆，是康拉德的稿酬有多高。布莱克伍德为此支付了他60英镑。所以按相对收入来算，这在今天大约相当于近5万英镑，这标志着当年这种写作的报酬有多丰厚。
then. And how highly rated Conrad is, I assume. I mean, it's not Conan Doyle, I accept, but at this point, he's not that highly rated. There's just so much money in short stories and journalism, far, far more than there is today. Great days. Yeah, great days. So he turns it round by the 6th
我想，这也说明康拉德的评价有多高。我的意思是，我承认他不是柯南·道尔，但在当时，他的评价其实没有那么高。只是短篇小说和新闻领域的资金太充足了，远远、远远超过今天。好日子啊。是的，好日子。所以他在
of February, he delivers 38,000 words to Blackwells, which I think is quite slow. I think it's pretty fast. That's three weeks work. That is three weeks work. Come on, mate. Anyway, it's published in February, March and April 1899. So just before we go to the break, for people who are not familiar with the book, or need reminding what has he produced? Most accounts that you read say that it's narrated by this guy Marlow. That's actually not true. Marlow is not the narrator. It's Russian dolls, isn't it? Yeah, there are narratives within narratives. So basically, the narrator is part of a group of people who are on this ship, the Nellie, off Gravesend in the Thames, so in England. And night is falling and they're all just hanging around on this boat, but they've
2月6日之前就赶出来了，向布莱克伍德交付了38,000字，我觉得这挺慢的。我觉得这挺快的。那是三周的工作量。那确实是三周的工作量。拜托，老兄。无论如何，它于1899年2月、3月和4月发表。所以在我们进入中场休息之前，对于不熟悉这本书、或者需要重温一下的人来说，他写了些什么？你读到的大多数描写都说它是通过马洛（Marlow）这个家伙的视角来叙述的。这其实不是真的。马洛不是叙述者。这是俄罗斯套娃，对吧？是的，那是叙事中的叙事。所以基本上，叙述者是一群人中的一员，他们在一艘船上，这艘船叫“内莉号”（the Nellie），停泊在泰晤士河上的格雷夫森德（Gravesend）附近，也就是在英国。夜幕降临，他们都只是在这艘船上闲逛，但他们必须
got to wait there for the turn of the tide, haven't they? They can't go home yet. And I think it makes it clear that the narrator in some ways is to be equated with Conrad, because narrator in some ways to be equated with Conrad because this hanging around on a ship on the Thames is exactly what Conrad was doing. And he did it with kind of various mates, one of whom was a company director, one of whom is an accountant, one of whom is a solicitor. And that maps exactly onto the description of the three people with Marlowe in the boat. Yeah. And Marlow is kind of leaning against the mast is sort of sitting down leaning against the mast.
在那里等潮水转向，对吧？他们还不能回家。而且我认为这清楚地表明，在某种程度上，叙述者可以等同于康拉德，因为在某种程度上，叙述者可以等同于康拉德，因为这种在泰晤士河上的船上闲逛正是康拉德一直在做的事情。而且他和几个伙伴一起做过这件事，其中一个是公司董事，一个是会计，还有一个是律师。这与马洛在船上的三个人的描述完全吻合。是的。马洛有点靠在桅杆上，可以说是坐着靠在桅杆上。
He's a, a sort of weather beaten sort of sea dog, you know, hard face, sea dog character, and he kicks off suddenly they're all just sitting around in a desultory way as night is falling and he doesn't talk about the Congo. He talks about Britain and he says very famously, and this also has been one of the dark places of the earth. And then he starts musing. You mean we, you talked about this time when we did long time ago, when we did an episode about Roman London. I think we opened with this message. Yeah. He says, what must it have been like to be a Roman in Britain?
他是一个历经风雨的海员形象，你知道，饱经风霜的强硬面孔，海员性格；然后他突然开口了，当时大家都在夜幕降临时百无聊赖地坐着，而他谈的不是刚果。他谈论的是英国，他说了一句非常著名的话：“这也是地球上的黑暗之地之一。”然后他开始沉思。你是说我们……你谈到过这个时间，我们很久以前做过一期关于罗马伦敦的节目。我想我们就是用这句话开场的。是的。他说，作为一个在英国的罗马人，会是什么感觉？
The feeling, you know, to be sent north from Italy or wherever. And you arrive in Britain and you have this feeling that the savagery, the utter savagery had closed around him. All that mysterious life of the wilderness that stirs in the forest, in the jungles, in the hearts of wild men. And that of course is very redolent of the Congo. And so also is his account of what it must have been like for a Roman soldier advancing inland here and there, a military camp lost in a wilderness,
那种感觉，你知道，从意大利或其他地方被派往北方。当你到达英国时，你会有一种野蛮状态——彻底的野蛮——将他包围的感觉。荒野中所有神秘的生命都在森林中、丛林中、在野蛮人的心中骚动。这当然让人非常联想到刚果。他对比罗马士兵向内地推进时所经历的情景的描述也是如此：四处散落，一个迷失在荒野中的军事营地，
like a needle in a bundle of hay. Yeah. Which of course is historically very inaccurate. But then he's very, he's very unsentimental about the Roman empire. He says it was just robbery with violence, aggravated murder on a great scale and men going at it blind as is very proper for those who tackle a darkness. And then he kind of goes on from that to think about empires in general. The conquest of the earth, which mostly means that taking it away from those who have a different
就像大海捞针一样。是的。这在历史上当然是非常不准确的。但随后他对罗马帝国表现得非常不加感情色彩。他说这只是一场伴随着暴力的抢劫，是一场大规模的加重谋杀，人们盲目地冲进去，正如那些面对黑暗的人所应当做的那样。然后他由此引申开去，思考帝国普遍面临的问题。对地球的征服——这主要意味着把它从那些拥有与我们不同的
complexion or slightly flatter noses than ourselves, is not a pretty thing when you look into it too much. What redeems it is the idea only that it's kind of a noble ideal, but in practice. Well, in that he has switched from the Romans to Europeans, hasn't he? He has indeed. He has indeed. And this then leads him to tell them a story. And this is the story of Heart of Darkness. And it's a story set in the past.
肤色或比我们略微扁平的鼻子的人手中夺走——当你深入探究时，并不是一件美丽的事情。能挽救它的唯一想法是它是一种崇高的理想，但在实践中……好吧，在这个地方，他已经从罗马人转换成了欧洲人，不是吗？他确实转换了。他确实转换了。然后这引导他给他们讲了一个故事。这就是《黑暗的心》的故事。这是一个以过去为背景的故事。
So it's not during, it's not set in 1899 when they're getting rubber. It's back in the heyday of ivory. And he says, you know, the word ivory rang in the air. You would think people were praying to it. Of course, that's as we'll discover. Literally true. That's literally true. Marlow, like Conrad is hired to take a steamboat up to the Congo, although the Congo is never
所以它不是在发生时，不是以人们在获取橡胶的1899年为背景。它回到了象牙的鼎盛时期。他说，你知道，“象牙”这个词在空中回响。你会以为人们在向它祈祷。当然，正如我们将发现的。字面意义上的真实。这字面意义上是真实的。马洛和康拉德一样，被雇佣去开着一艘汽船逆刚果河而上，尽管刚果从未
named. Well, Dominic also, I mean, Belgium is never named and Leopold is never named and Brussels is never named. It's what's it's called the white and sepulchre. Yeah. The sepulchre city or something. Exactly. Yeah. So, but it's clear, you know, there's no, it's clear, I think, what, where we're talking about. But I suppose it kind of universalizes it a bit. Yes, I think so. I mean, I think so.
被点名。嗯，多米尼克，我的意思是——比利时也从未被点名，利奥波德从未被点名，布鲁塞尔从未被点名。它被称为什么？它被称为“白色陵墓”。是的。“陵墓之城”或类似的名字。完全正确。是的。所以，但很清楚，你知道，没有……我认为很清楚我们在谈论什么。不过我想这在某种程度上让它具有了一点普遍性。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，我也这么认为。
Exactly. Yeah. I think it definitely universalizes it, which is why I think it's completely reasonable to set it in Vietnam in apocalypse now or whatever. So his job is to go up the river to collect this agent, Mr. Kurtz from the interior. Everybody says to him, are you going to see Mr. Kurtz? Mr. Kurtz is absolutely brilliant. Mr. Kurtz is, Mr. Kurtz, he's half English, he's half French.
完全正确。是的。我认为它绝对具有普遍性，这就是为什么我认为把它设定在《现代启示录》中的越南或其他地方是完全合理的。所以他的工作就是逆流而上，去内陆接回这位特工库尔茨先生。每个人都对他说：“你要去见库尔茨先生吗？库尔茨先生绝对才华横溢。库尔茨先生是……库尔茨先生，他有一半英国血统，有一半法国血统。”
Although people say all Europe had contributed to the making of Kurtz. He's a brilliant writer. He's painted this oil, beautiful oil sketch of a woman holding a torch, kind of a figure of progress, of course. He is, and I quote, an emissary of pity and science and progress. He is the enlightenment. He is Western civilization. You know, he's, he's just absolutely brilliant. But he is also praised as the man who gets as much ivory as all the other agents put together. So he is also being praised for his acquisitiveness and whatever qualities are required to obtain
尽管人们说整个欧洲都为库尔茨的塑造出过力。他是个杰出的作家。他画了这幅油画，一幅美丽的女子的油画草图，手里拿着火炬，当然是某种进步的象征。他确实是——我引述原话——“怜悯、科学和进步的使者”。他是启蒙运动。他是西方文明。你知道，他简直是才华横溢。但他也受到赞誉，被称为那个搜集的象牙和所有其他特工加起来一样多的人。所以他也因其贪婪以及获得
that amount of ivory. Yeah. So there is a darkness there right from the start. There is indeed. And quite early on, Marlow starts to get some kind of sense that all is not well with Mr. Kurtz. And at one point later on, not well with Mr. Kurtz. And at one point later on, he discovers that Mr. Kurtz has written this enormous report for the international society for the
那么多象牙所需的任何品质而受到赞誉。是的。所以从一开始就存在着一种黑暗。确实如此。很早的时候，马洛就开始察觉到库尔茨先生有些不对劲。而在后来的某个时候，不是库尔茨先生身体不好。在后来的某个时候，他发现库尔茨先生为国际
suppression of savage customs. And it's a brilliant piece of work. You know, it's amazingly well written, but it ends with this weird scrawled phrase, exterminate all the brutes. Which kind of sets alarm bells ringing I think another of those kind of terrifyingly quotable phrases yeah so Marla gets the boat up river he has a series of quite scary adventures I say adventures but they're not really are they thing is they're riffs on the kind of adventures you would see in boys stories but they're told in a really unsettling, like
野蛮习俗抑制协会写了这篇庞大的报告。这是一部杰出的作品。你知道，它写得好得惊人，但它的结尾却有着这样一句奇怪的乱涂乱画的话：“消灭所有野兽。”这让人敲响了警钟，我想……这也是那些令人毛骨悚然的引文之一。是的，所以马洛乘船逆流而上，他经历了一系列相当可怕的冒险。我说是冒险，但其实并不是，对吧？问题在于，它们是对你在男孩冒险故事中会看到的那些冒险的变奏，但它们的讲述方式非常令人不安，仿佛
he can't understand what's going on. But also nothing ever happens. So that fun stuff about hearing drums in the distance or whatever in in Ryder Haggard, that would immediately presage an attack that would involve guns and heroism and all kinds of stuff. I mean, nothing like that ever happens. Well, there is an attack when they reach the station. Remember, there's all the spears that are thrown at them and the bloke next to him is killed actually.
他根本无法理解发生了什么。而且也从来没有真正发生过什么。所以在H·莱德·哈格德（Ryder Haggard）的小说中，那些在远处听到鼓声之类的有趣事情，会立即预示着一场涉及枪支、英雄主义和各种惊险场面的袭击。我的意思是，从来没有发生过类似的事情。嗯，当他们到达据点时确实遭到了袭击。还记得吗，有无数长矛向他们投掷，而且他身旁的一个家伙 faktisk 被杀死了。
But it's not standing in the middle of King Solomon's mind being, I mean, it's just not that kind of adventure. No, it's not at all. And Marlow is just standing there basically doing nothing during all of it. He's not an asset of active, exciting protagonist. Loading his rifle or that kind of thing. Anyway, they get to Kurtz's station. All the worst suspicions are confirmed. The station is surrounded by posts with severed heads. And I don't want to spoil the story completely for people who haven't read it, but, um, as the company manager puts it, Kurtz's methods have proved unsound.
但这并不是站在所罗门王的宝藏中间……我的意思是，它根本不是那种冒险。不，完全不是。在这一切过程中，马洛基本上只是站在那里什么也没做。他不是那种积极、令人兴奋的主角。没有装填步枪或类似的事情。无论如何，他们到达了库尔茨的据点。所有最糟糕的怀疑都得到了证实。据点四周都是插着人头断桩。我不想把故事的结局完全剧透给那些没读过的人，但是……正如公司经理所说的那样，库尔茨的方法已被证明是不健全的。
He's been going about his business in an unsound manner. I mean, he's basically being worshipped by the locals as a god, but he's behaving very violently. Kurtz himself is a very sick man. He's an emaciated ghostly figure on a stretcher. So not like Marlon Brando. Not like Marlon Brando at all, but very like this bloke Klein that Conrad himself had picked up.
他一直在用一种不健全的方式处理他的业务。我的意思是，他基本上被当地人当作神明来崇拜，但他的行为却非常暴力。库尔茨本人是一个病得很重的人。他是一个躺在担架上骨瘦如柴、宛如幽灵般的人物。所以一点也不像马龙·白兰度。一点也不像马龙·白兰度，但非常像康拉德自己曾接载过的那个叫克莱因的家伙。
Marlow and Kurtz have a series of chats, slightly strange chats, very elliptical, hard to elusive, hard to work out exactly what they're talking about. Kurtz is dying, clearly. Kurtz says to Marlow, oh, it's terrible shame. I'll never have the chance to carry out my, I had immense plans, he says. It's going to carry out great things, but we never really find out what those immense plans add up to. Anyway, they finally head back downstream with Kurtz, who is dying. And then we get to that scene that you opened with Tom, where Kurtz,
马洛和库尔茨进行了一系列交谈，有点奇怪的交谈，非常隐晦，难以捉摸，很难弄清楚他们到底在谈论什么。库尔茨显然快死了。库尔茨对马洛说：“哦，太遗憾了。我永远没有机会去实施我的……我曾有宏伟的计划，”他说。“我本打算做出一番伟大的成就，但我们从未真正弄清楚那些宏伟的计划到底意味着什么。”无论如何，他们最终带着垂死的库尔茨顺流而下返回。然后我们就来到了你开篇时提到的那个场景，汤姆，当时库尔茨，
his final words is lying there and he says, it's like he's looking into the distance, and he says, or is he looking into his own soul? We don't know. And he says, the horror, the horror. Um, it's a really famous death scene. There's a brilliant essay for people who are interested online by the New Yorker's critic, David Denby. He first wrote it in 1995 and he calls it the most famous literary death scene
他躺在那里，说出了他最后的遗言，就好像他在凝视着远方，他说——或者他是在凝视自己的灵魂？我们不得而知。他说：“恐怖！恐怖！”嗯，这是一个非常著名的死亡场景。对于感兴趣的人来说，《纽约客》的评论家大卫·丹比（David Denby）在网上写过一篇精彩的文章。他最初于1995年写下这篇文章，称其为自莎士比亚以来最著名的文学死亡场景。
since Shakespeare. And I think it's very famous now because of Marlon Brando, because of apocalypse. Now, I mean, since Shakespeare, but you might say since Christopher Marlowe and the death of Faustus who has sold his soul in return for earthly riches and then gets plunged down into hell. And it can't be a coincidence. I think that Marlowe, the character who meets with Kurtz shares the name with the playwright who wrote that drama.
我想现在它之所以如此著名，是因为马龙·白兰度，因为《现代启示录》。我的意思是，自莎士比亚以来，但你也可以说是自克里斯托弗·马洛（Christopher Marlowe）以及浮士德之死以来——浮士德为了尘世的财富出卖了自己的灵魂，随后坠入地狱。这绝对不可能是巧合。我认为，与库尔茨会面的角色马洛（Marlow），其名字与写下那部戏剧的剧作家不谋而合。
It's a nice parallel. Contemporary of Shakespeare's. Exactly. Now in Apocalypse Now, for people who've seen the film, this is basically the end. Kurtz dies, end of the film. But interestingly, that's not the end of Heart of Darkness. Marlowe comes back to Europe and something in him has changed. He talks again and again about feeling loyal to Kurtz.
这是一个很好的平行对应。与莎士比亚同时代的人。完全正确。现在，在看过这部电影的观众看来，《现代启示录》中的这一幕基本上就是结局。库尔茨死了，电影结束。但有趣的是，这并不是《黑暗的心》的结局。马洛回到了欧洲，他内心的某样东西已经改变了。他一次又一次地谈到对库尔茨的忠诚感。
He says that Kurtz will have a bit of the reading in the next half, I think, that Kurtz has stepped over the edge of something and seen something profound. We don't know what it is. As a result of this, Marlow comes back and he goes to Brussels and he feels completely alienated from life in Brussels. He's had an experience that has changed him. Now, Kurtz has given him a packet of papers and trusted it to him.
他说，在接下来的半部里，库尔茨会有一点……我想，库尔茨已经跨越了某种东西的边缘，看到了深刻的东西。我们不知道那是什么。正因为如此，马洛回来了，他去了布鲁塞尔，对布鲁塞尔的生活感到彻底的疏离。他经历了一次改变了他人生的体验。现在，库尔茨交给他一包文件，并托付给他。
And the very last scene of the novel is him giving the papers to Kurtz's grieving fiance. Because all the owners of the company want these papers, don't they? Yeah. And Marlow is saying that, you know, I don't have them. And also just to say one thing that we admitted, Kurtz has had an
小说的最后一幕就是他把文件交给了库尔茨悲痛欲绝的未婚妻。因为公司的所有所有者都想要这些文件，对吧？是的。而马洛则说，你知道，我没有它们。而且还要补充一件我们刚刚漏掉的事：库尔茨有一个爱他的非洲女人。没错。而且她实际上，我认为是整部中篇小说中最具H·莱德·哈格德风格的人物。她戴着某种疯狂的头饰之类的。我觉得这与这篇中篇小说中的其他一切都有点格格不入。我完全同意你的看法。我认为那是书中唯一一个向晚期维多利亚时代非洲情节剧妥协的时刻。
African woman who loves him. That's right. And she is actually, I think the most Ryder Haggard figure in the whole thing. She's got kind of a crazy headdress or something. And I felt kind of slightly out of tune with everything else in the novella. I totally agree with you. I think that's the one moment in the book where Conrad yields to kind of late Victorian African melodrama.
我同意。这个女人极其震撼、雕塑般美丽，她站在那里，你知道，大声哀号。挥舞着长矛，还有……是的。所有这一切。有点像布狄卡（Boudicca）式的人物。无论如何，他把这些文件交给了未婚妻，令他惊恐的是，她说：“告诉我他死的时候的事，他对你说的最后一句话是什么？”而马洛在整个故事中做的最后一件事情就是直视她的眼睛，对她撒了谎，说他吐露的最后一个词是你的名字。
Agreed. In this woman who's like incredibly impressive and statuesque and sort of, she stands there, you know, lamenting loudly. Waving spears and... Yeah. And all of this. Kind of a Boudicca figure. Anyway, he hands over these papers to the fiance and to his horror, she says, tell me
好吧，我的意思是，除非她的名字叫“恐怖”。是的，这看起来太不可能了。看起来不太可能。无论如何，多米尼克，谢谢你。这就是康拉德的一生以及《黑暗的心》的剧情。
about when he died, what was the last thing he said to you? And the very last thing that Marlow does in the whole story is he looks her in the eye and he lies to her and he says the last word he pronounced was your name. Well, I mean, unless her name was horror. Yeah, seems very unlikely. Seems unlikely. Anyway, Dominic, thank you. So that's the life of Conrad and the plot of Heart of Darkness.
但多米尼克，这一切究竟意味着什么？这一切到底是怎么回事？我们将在中场休息后揭晓答案。在我们进入中场休息之前，我真的很想向大家推荐另一档戈德杭格（Goldhanger）播客《传奇》（Legacy），由彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan）和阿富阿·赫什（Afua Hirsch）主持。没错。他们穿梭于历史的编年史中，重访历史上一些最著名的男女名流的一生，并探究他们是否配得上他们所拥有的名声。而在这一季中，他们将目光投向了也许是历史上最著名的领袖之一：
But Dominic, what does it all mean? What's it all about? We will find out after the break. Now before we get to the break, I would really like to tell you about another Goldhanger podcast, Legacy, hosted by Peter Frankopan and Afua Hirsch. That's right. They go through the annals of history and revisit the lives of some of the most famous men and women to ever have lived and ask if they have the reputation they deserve. And this season, they are looking at perhaps one of the most famous leaders of all time,
成吉思汗（Genghis Khan），这位蒙古领袖的帝国从朝鲜一直延伸到东欧部分地区。多米尼克，正如彼得·弗兰科潘——我的板球球友——会告诉你的一样，其实它的发音是“成吉思”（Chingis）。你知道吗？你知道吗，汤姆，这对我来说是一个惊人的启示，我以前不知道。你居然不知道。成吉思汗，Chinggis Khan，无论你想怎么叫他，都是一个非凡的人物。我的意思是，一个令人难以置信的残暴人物。据说他的征服以及他直接继承者的征服导致了……我想大概有4千万人的死亡，这大约占当时世界人口的10%。
Genghis Khan, the Mongol leader whose empire expanded from Korea to parts of Eastern Europe. And Dominic, as Peter Frankopan, a cricketing compadre of mine, would tell you, it's actually pronounced Chingis. Did you know that? Do you know Tom, that's an amazing revelation to me, I didn't know that. You did not know that. Genghis Khan, Chinggis Khan, however you want to call him, extraordinary figure. I mean, unbelievably brutal figure. It's said that his conquests and those of his immediate successors resulted, I think something like 40 million deaths, which would be about 10% of the world population at the
然而，汤姆，这只是故事的一个方面，对吧？因为他难道不是也在他的帝国中开创了“驿站”（Yam）邮政系统吗？而且我读到过，他对女性的处理方式前后完全不一致。是的，因为他和他的军队当然曾将性暴力作为战争武器，但在某一个时刻，他也确实禁止了绑架妇女的行为。这个系列节目绝对是一场非凡的听觉盛宴，很大程度上是因为彼得曾写过畅销书《丝绸之路》（The Silk Roads），这本书讲的就是成吉思汗统治的世界。你很难找到比彼得·弗兰科潘更了解蒙古人的人了。再加上联合主持人阿富阿·赫什（Afio Hirsch），你一定会大饱耳福。所以，现在就去你获取播客的任何地方收听《传奇》，或者在Wondery上提前收听无广告的剧集吧。Wondery。库尔茨是个非凡的人。他有话要说。他说出来了。既然我自己也曾在边缘窥视过，我就更能理解他那双眼睛的含义了——那双眼睛看不到蜡烛的火焰，却足以拥抱整个宇宙，敏锐足以穿透所有在黑暗中跳动的心脏。他已经做出了总结。
time. And yet, Tom, that's only one side of the story, isn't it? Because did he not also develop the Yam postal system across his empire and his treatment of women I read was entirely inconsistent. Yes because he and his army certainly used sexual violence as a weapon of war but also at one point he did ban the kidnapping of women. And the series is a really extraordinary listen in no small part because Peter wrote the bestseller The Silk Roads which is all about Genghis's part of the world. And you will be hard pressed to find someone who knows more about the Mongols than Peter Frankapan. And with AfioHersh as well as co-host, you're all in for a real treat. So listen to Legacy
他已经做出了判决。恐怖。他是个非凡的人。毕竟，这是某种信仰的表达。它有坦诚。它有信念。在其低语中有一种震撼人心的反叛音符。它有着惊鸿一瞥的真理那骇人的面容，有着欲望与恨意的奇异交织。
now wherever you get your podcasts or listen to episodes early and ad free at Wandery. Wondery. Kurtz was a remarkable man. He had something to say. He said it. Since I had peeped over the edge myself, I understand better the meaning of his stare, that could not see the flame of the candle, but was wide enough to embrace the whole universe, piercing enough to penetrate all the hearts that beat in the darkness. He had summed it up.
这就是马洛在《黑暗的心》临近结尾时，在库尔茨死后对库尔茨做出的最终评价。我想，你知道，《黑暗的心》是一个非常、非常贴切的书名。那种“存在着某种你无法看透的神秘事物”的感觉，库尔茨以某种奇特的方式体现了这一点。你会有一种感受到深渊宏大的意味，但又很难确切地说出到底是什么潜伏在这些深渊之中。所以，多米尼克，我的意思是，这些就是给你的问题。
He had judged. The horror. He was a remarkable man. After all, this was the expression of some sort of belief. It had candor. It had conviction. It had a vibrating note of revolt in its whisper. It had the appalling face of a glimpsed truth, the strange commingling of desire and hate.
那么，库尔茨究竟看到了什么？真相是什么？恐怖究竟是什么？潜伏在那些深渊之中。所以，多米尼克，我的意思是，这些就是给你的问题。那么，库尔茨究竟看到了什么？真相是什么？恐怖究竟是什么？这是他在自己身上看到的东西吗？这是他在刚果看到的东西吗？这是他在帝国主义本质中看到的东西吗？这是关于人类境况本身的某种东西吗？
So that's the verdict that Marlow delivers on Kurtz after his death towards the end of Heart of Darkness. And I guess, you know, Heart of Darkness is a very, very well chosen title. That sense that there is something that a mystery that you can't penetrate, which Kurtz in some strange way embodies. And you have the sense of kind of great depths, but it's hard exactly to say what lurks in those depths. And so Dominic, I mean, here are the questions for you.
我的意思是，这到底是怎么回事？这是一个很好的问题，汤姆。好吧，我有一堆问题要问你。是的，我们会在这一期中回答所有这些问题。你有45分钟时间。拿起你的笔。现在开始。一个多世纪以来，文学学者们一直在试图回答这些问题。最后，我们要揭晓答案了。
So what is it that Kurtz has seen? What is the truth? What is the horror? lurks in those depths. And so Dominic, I mean, here are the questions for you. So what is it that Kurtz has seen? What is the truth? What is the horror? Is it something he's seen in himself? Is it something he's seen in the Congo? Is it something he has seen in the nature of imperialism? Is it something about the human condition full stop?
太棒了。这就像肯尼迪遇刺案一样。所以在库尔茨本人身上，许多学者试图争辩说他是一个真实存在的人物，并试图找出启发康拉德灵感的人是谁，我认为有三四个候选人是一再被提及的。所以其中一个候选人是一个名叫埃德蒙·巴托洛特（Edmund Bartolot）少校的家伙，很遗憾地告诉大家，他是一名英国军官。他曾与亨利·莫顿·斯坦利（Henry Morton Stanley）一起去营救……
I mean, what is going on? That's a very good question, Tom. Well, I have loads of questions for you. Yeah, we'll answer all those questions in this. You have 45 minutes. Pick up your pen. Start now. Literary scholars have tried for more than a century to answer those questions. And finally, we can reveal the answers.
他的故事太复杂了。基本上他们去苏丹营救一个并不需要救援的埃及总督，名叫埃明·帕夏（Emin Pasha）。这个叫巴托洛特的家伙表现得——可以说——非常糟糕。他疯了。他开始疯狂地鞭笞人们。他给许多人戴上铁链，开始到处跑去咬女人。真的吗？
Brilliant. It's like the Kennedy assassination. So on Kurtz himself, loads of scholars have tried to argue that he's a real person and they've tried to find out who Conrad was inspired by and I think there are Three or four candidates that come up again and again So one candidate is a bloke called Major Edmund Bartolot and he I'm sorry to say was a British officer He had gone with Stanley Henry Morton Stanley to rescue
是的。行为非常恶劣。最终这个非洲本地人开枪打死了他。他开始到处跑去咬女人。真的吗？是的。行为非常恶劣。最终这个非洲本地人开枪打死了他，他的一生也就此结束了。每个人都说：“天哪，这简直是对英国最糟糕的宣传！让我们再也不要提这事了。”所以这就是那个叫巴托洛特的家伙。他很可能是库尔茨的灵感来源之一。然后是一个叫亚瑟·霍迪斯特（Arthur Hodister）的比利时人。
And he has such a complicated story. Basically they went to rescue an Egyptian governor called Emin Pasha who didn't need rescuing in the Sudan. And this guy Bartolot behaved as fair to say very poorly. He went mad. He started flocking people wildly. He put loads of people in chains and he started running around biting women. Really?
我觉得对于一个比利时人来说这是一个奇怪的名字，但事实就是如此。他是一个象牙商人，和库尔茨一样在这方面才华横溢。他冷酷无情。他拥有一个由当地女性组成的后宫。有传言说当地人把他当作神明来崇拜，但他的结局与库尔茨截然不同。他被斯瓦希里奴隶贩子折磨、斩首，根据某些说法，还被他们吃掉了，因为他闯入了他们的地盘。这会是《黑暗的心》的一个好结局。
Yeah. Very bad behavior. And eventually this African bloke shot him dead and he started running around biting women. Really? Yeah. Very bad behavior. And eventually this African bloke shot him dead and that was the end of him. And everyone said, God almighty, what a terrible advert for Britain. Let's never speak of this again. So there's that guy Bartolot. He possibly is an inspiration for Kurtz. Then there's a Belgian called Arthur Hodister.
那将是一个意想不到的结局。是的。然后是一个叫卡尔·彼得斯（Carl Peters）的德国人。他基本上就是德国版的亨利·莫顿斯坦利。他发起了自己的远征去营救那个根本不需要救援的叫埃明帕夏的家伙。他在赞比西河沿岸发现了古代遗址。他身上基本上有点印第安纳·琼斯（Indiana Jones）的影子。不幸的是，连德国人都对这个人感到尴尬。
Strange name for a Belgian, I always think, but there you go. He was an ivory trader and was brilliant at it like Kurtz. He was ruthless. He had a harem of local women. There were rumors that local people worshiped him as a God, but he came to a very different end from Kurtz. He was tortured, beheaded, and according to some accounts, eaten by Swahili slave traders for kind of intruding on their patch. That would have been a good end to Heart of Darkness.
他也变得有点疯。他极其暴力。他的绰号是“绞刑架彼得斯”（hangman Peters），因为基本上，你知道，你对他说声早安，他就把你给吊死了。他非常暴力。甚至连当时行为相当糟糕——可以说非常糟糕——的德国人在西南非洲此时的表现，甚至连他们都为他感到羞耻，这就说明了一切。
It would have been an unexpected end. Yeah. Then there's a guy called Carl Peters who was a German. He was basically German, his answer to Henry Morton Stanley. He launched his own expedition to rescue this blow game in Pascha, who didn't need rescuing. He discovered ancient sites along the Zambezi river. He's basically got a bit of the Indiana Jones. Unfortunately, even Germans were embarrassed by this.
然后是最后一个候选人，亚当·霍赫希尔德（Adam Hochschild）在他的书《利奥波德国王的鬼魂》（King Leopold's Ghost）中提到过，是一个叫莱昂·罗姆（Leon Rom）的家伙。罗姆是个比利时人。他是刚果独立国家宪兵队（Force Publique）的一名队长。和库尔茨一样，他喜欢画画和写作，还收集蝴蝶，这倒挺不错的。就像弗拉基米尔·纳博科夫（Vladimir Nabokov）和墨西哥皇帝马克西米利安一样，但他也是一个痴迷的猎人。他有很多非洲情妇。
He also went a bit mad. He was incredibly violent. His nickname was hangman Peters because basically, you know, you said good morning to him and he hanged you. He was very violent. And even the Germans who were behaving quite badly, it's fair to say, or indeed very badly in South West Africa at this point, even they're ashamed of him, which tells his own story.
他当时——我引述原话——享有“因琐碎原因残杀大量民众”的名声，并且在他的据点里保留了一处用人头环绕的花坛。哦，这真的很库尔茨。这非常库尔茨。正如吉斯瓦夫·尼达（Giswaf Nida）在他关于康拉德的传记中所说的那样，康拉德很可能借鉴了所有这些例子，但很显然，库尔茨既是所有人，又谁都不是。正如尼达所说，库尔茨的原型既源自文学和哲学传统，也源自现实生活中非洲人的行为。嗯，这里有一种拜伦式英雄的特质——那种因从经验中获得的惨痛知识而得到升华的人。我的意思是，这绝对是一种文学母题。你提到了我认为最显而易见的东西，那就是浮士德。所以浮士德把灵魂卖给了魔鬼，不仅是马洛，歌德显然也写过浮士德，然后托马斯·曼（Thomas Mann）会在康拉德之后几十年再写浮士德。书中有一些提及：马洛在《黑暗的心》中某处说过，库尔茨在“这片土地的恶魔中占据了高位”，后来他又谈到黑暗的力量是如何准备将他占为己有的。所以这种“库尔茨把灵魂卖给魔鬼”的想法，
And then the final candidate, which Adam Hochschild mentions in his book, King Leopold's Ghost, is a guy called Leon Rom. Rom was a Belgian. He was a captain in the Force public. Like Kurtz, he liked painting and writing and he collected butterflies, which is nice. Like Vladimir Nabokov and Maximilian Emperor Maximilian of Mexico, but also he's an obsessive hunter. He had loads of African concubines.
你知道，这是一个非常古老且属于欧洲的概念，但库尔茨身上也有一些新的东西。他是进步的化身。别忘了他是那么有才华。他是那么……他是文明的缩影，是文明的化身。而且有一种观点认为，我认为他在那篇长篇报告中做的事情……记住他写了那份很长的报告。是的，就是“消灭所有野兽”。完全正确。有一种观点认为，那份报告本身就是欧洲在非洲计划的化身。
He had at the time and I quote the reputation of having killed masses of people for petty reasons and he kept a flower bed at his station ringed with human heads. Oh, that's very Kurtz. Which is very Kurtz. So as Giswaf Nida says in his biography of Conrad, Conrad may well have drawn on all these examples, but it's clear that Kurtz is all of them and none of them. As Nida says, the model for Kurtz comes from literary and philosophical tradition as much as it does from real life African behavior. Well there's the quality of the Byronic hero, the man who is elevated by the terrible knowledge
为了将其分类、记录在案、把一切都变成账目和账本。这一切始于拿破仑远征埃及。完全正确。把非洲记录在纸面上并控制它、绘制它的地图。非常爱德华·萨义德（Edward Said）。是的，这实际上就是殖民主义的行为。好吧，欧洲殖民主义。欧洲殖民主义，是的。所以，这究竟是一个关于殖民主义的故事吗？
that he has won from experience. I mean it's definitely a kind of literary trope. You mentioned what I think is the obvious thing which is Faust. So Faust sold his soul to the devil and it's not just Marlowe but obviously Goethe wrote about Faust and then Thomas Mann will write about Faust a few decades after Conrad. And there are a few references Marlowe says at one point in Harte Danas, Kurtz has taken a high seat among the devils of the land and later on he talks about how the powers of darkness are about to claim him for their own. So this idea that Kurtz has soul is sold to the devil.
库尔茨是其中一切错误之事的化身吗？在某种层面上，答案显然是肯定的。马洛在开篇时说的那几句关于“把地球从鼻子比我们扁的人手中夺走”的台词是非常尖锐的。在书的后面，稍微晚一点，在马洛真正去刚果之前，他去拜访了他的姑妈，他的姑妈一直在读报纸上关于非洲和帝国的报道，她说：“哦，太棒了。太喜欢这个计划了。把那些无知的成百上千的人从他们可怕的生活方式中拯救出来。”而马洛实际上对她说了——甚至在他去之前——
You know, it's a very old idea and kind of European, but there's also something new about Kurtz. He's the embodiment of progress. Remember that he's so talented. He's so, he is the epitome, he's the embodiment of civilization. And there is an argument, I think that what he's doing in that long, remember he writes that very long report. Yeah, so exterminate all the brutes. Exactly. There's an argument that that report is in itself the embodiment of the European project in Africa.
他说：“这全是关于钱的。这家公司是为了利润而运转的。”你知道，他对是什么在动机上推动这一切并不抱任何感情色彩。当然，当他到达刚果时，他所看到的一切都可以直接写进一份关于帝国罪行的起诉书里：头骨、刚果……他所看到的一切都可以直接写进一份关于帝国罪行的起诉书里：头骨、骨骼、暴力，所有诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，让我印象深刻的一点是，有点像《世界大战》（War of the Worlds）——Wells将欧洲殖民主义的恐怖转嫁到了英国身上——有一种感觉，
To categorise, to set down on, to turn everything into accounts and ledgers. Which began with Napoleon going to Egypt. Exactly. To put Africa down on paper and control it and map it. Very Edward Said. Yeah, that is the act of colonialism effectively. Well, European colonialism. European colonialism, yeah. So is this therefore a story about colonialism
康拉德偶尔也在做同样的事情。所以整个开篇把英国比作非洲。但同时，还有一个非常精彩的片段。马洛看着所有被废弃的村庄，他说：“如果一大群突然武装着可怕武器的非洲人开始出现在肯特郡迪尔（Deal）和格雷夫森德（Gravesend）之间的公路上，左右抓捕乡巴佬来为他们扛重物，我想那附近的每一个农场和村舍很快就会空无一人。”当然，这预示着纳粹日后将在欧洲腹地引入的奴隶劳工制度。我认为这绝对正确，而且我认为书的开头通过将发生在英国的事情进行置换，
and is Kurtz the embodiment of all that's wrong with it? At one level, I think the answer is obviously yes. Marlowe at the beginning is given those lines about taking the earth away from people with flatter noses than ourselves that are kind of very pointed. Later on in the book, only a little bit later, before Marlow actually goes to the Congo, he goes to visit his aunt and his aunt has been reading newspaper stories about Africa and empire and she says, oh, it's brilliant. Love this project. Weaning those ignorant millions from their horrid ways. And Marlow actually says to her, this is even before he's gone.
书的开头通过将发生在英国的事情进行置换，使得康拉德非常清楚地意识到这具有更广泛的含义，这是一种普遍的信息。但这里面还有更复杂的情况。框架叙述者非常热衷于大英帝国，因为当他在格雷夫森德时，他沉思着海上的流浪骑士、神圣之火火种的播火者、人类的梦想、英联邦的种子、帝国的萌芽。人们带着英国性的火花从这里扬帆起航，这难道不是很棒吗？马洛，另一个叙述者，他也认为大英帝国很棒。他有一次说他看到了一张地图，上面有很大一片非洲被涂上了英国皇家领地的粉红色或红色。
He says, it's about money. The company has run for profit. You know, he's unsentimental about what is, um, what is motivating this. And of course, then when he gets to the Congo, everything that he sees could come from a charge sheet about the crimes of empire, the skulls, the Congo, everything that he sees could come from a charge sheet about the crimes of empire, the skulls, the skeletons, the violence, all of that kind of thing. I mean, one of the things that strikes me about it, a bit like War of the Worlds, where Wells transposes the horrors of European colonialism to Britain, there's a sense that
他说：“哦，看到这个真好，因为人们知道那里正在进行真正的伟大的工作。”也就是说，大英帝国与其他帝国不同。非常吉普林（Kipling）式。但我们知道康拉德本人也是这么想的。就在他完成《黑暗的心》之后不久，布尔战争（Boer War）爆发了，他的波兰亲戚对他说：“你怎么看待这件事？你知道，一个帝国对抗一小群布尔人，你知道，这难道不让你想起什么吗？”而他说：“什么？”
occasionally that Conrad is doing the same thing. So the whole opening with Britain as Africa. But also there's a kind of an amazing passage. So Marlow is looking out at all the villages that are abandoned. And he says, well, if loads of Africans suddenly armed with terrifying weapons started appearing on the road that stretches between Deal and Graves End in Kent, catching the yokels right and left to carry heavy loads for them. I fancy every farm and cottage thereabouts would get empty very soon. And of course that is a prefiguring of the slave labor in due course that the Nazis will introduce in the heart of Europe. I think that's absolutely right and I think the beginning of the book by transposing what happens to Britain,
偶尔会发现康拉德也在做同样的事情。所以整个开篇把英国比作非洲。但其中也有一段非常精彩的描写。马洛看着所有被废弃的村庄。他说，如果有大量全副武装、手持可怕武器的非洲人突然出现在肯特郡迪尔和格雷夫森德之间的路上，到处抓捕乡下人为他们扛重物，我想那附近的每一个农场和村舍都会很快空无一人。当然，这预示着日后纳粹将在欧洲腹地引入的奴隶劳工。我认为这绝对是正确的，而且我认为通过转换发生在英国的事情，书的开头……
the beginning of the book by transposing what happens to Britain, it makes it very obvious that Conrad is conscious that this has a wider implication, that this is kind of a universal message. But here's the complication within the complication. The framing narrator is very keen on the British Empire because while he's at Gravesend, he muses on the night errants of the sea, bearers of a spark from the sacred fire, the dreams of men, the seed of Commonwealth, the germ of empires. People have sailed out from here with the spark of Britishness and isn't that brilliant? Marlow, the other narrator, he also thinks the British Empire is brilliant. He says at one point he sees a map with a lot of Africa splashed with British Imperial pink or red.
通过转换发生在英国的事情，书的开头清楚地表明，康拉德意识到这具有更广泛的含义，这是一种普遍的信息。但复杂之处在于复杂之中。框架叙述者对大英帝国非常热心，因为当他在格雷夫森德时，他沉思着海上的游侠、圣火火种的传递者、人类的梦想、英联邦的种子、帝国的萌芽。人们带着英国的特质从这里扬帆起航，这难道不是很棒吗？另一个叙述者马洛也认为大英帝国很棒。他在某个地方说，他看到一张地图上，非洲的大片土地涂上了英国帝国主义的粉红色或红色。
And he said, oh, that's good to see because one knows that real work is being done there. IE the British Empire is different from other empires. So very Kipling. But we know that Conrad himself thought that. So just after he's finished Harte Danis, the Burr War breaks out and his Polish relatives say to him, what do you make of this? You know, an empire against a little people at the Burrs, you know, doesn't ring any bells. And he says, what?
他说，哦，看到这个真好，因为人们知道真正的工作正在那里进行。也就是说，大英帝国与其他帝国不同。非常吉卜林式的风格。但我们知道康拉德本人也这么认为。就在他写完《黑暗的心》之后，布尔战争爆发了，他的波兰亲戚对他说，你怎么看这件事？一个帝国对抗布尔人这样一个弱小的人群，你不觉得似曾相识吗？他说，什么？
The British are brilliant. Liberty can only be found under the English flag all over the world. So he's for the Burr War. And then after he died, his great friend and collaborator, Ford Malick Ford said of him, a line that always amuses me, the British Empire was for Conrad, the perfection of all human perfections. So Conrad obviously a brilliant judge of, of empires, but this has led some people to say, well, hold on, you know, you can't celebrate this book as a, as a
英国人太聪明了。全世界只有在英国国旗下才能找到自由。所以他是支持布尔战争的。在他死后，他伟大的朋友兼合作者福特·马多克斯·福特曾这样评价他，这句话总是让我忍俊不禁：对康拉德而言，大英帝国是所有人世完美之大成。因此，康拉德显然是个极具洞察力的帝国裁判官，但这却导致一些人说，等等，你知道的，你不能把这本书当作对……
criticism of empire. In fact, let's go further. This book is itself massively tainted with the crimes of Empire. In fact, let's go further. This book is itself massively tainted with the crimes of Empire. It's a tainted example of imperialist literature. Although, if you read it and you didn't know about Coronet's enthusiasm for British imperialism, would you necessarily recognize that? Well, there are at least two critics who think you would.
批判帝国的作品来颂扬。事实上，我们更进一步说。这本书本身就严重玷污于帝国的罪行。事实上，我们更进一步说。这本书本身就严重玷污于帝国的罪行。它是帝国主义文学的一个被玷污的样本。不过，如果你读了它，却不知道康拉德对英国帝国主义的热情，你一定会认出来吗？嗯，至少有两位评论家认为你会。
So one of them, I think you mentioned him already, didn't you? Edward Said, Palestinian American critic, one of the most famous literary critics of the last half century, who wrote a brilliantly influential book, shall we say, called Orientalism, which some scholars think is a terrible book. I think it's brilliant. I think you say it's brilliant. Anyway, Said says, yes, you would recognize comrades as an imperialist because he doesn't ever reject imperialism in his book. He doesn't give the, you know, his book should end with people being given their freedom or some savage critique of the imperialism that has enslaved them. I mean, that is what you get.
所以其中一个，我想你已经提到他了，不是吗？爱德华·萨义德，巴勒斯坦裔美国评论家，过去半个世纪中最著名的文学评论家之一，他写了一本影响深远的出色著作，我们可以称之为《东方主义》，一些学者认为这是一本糟糕的书。我觉得它很棒。我想你也觉得它很棒。无论如何，萨义德说，是的，你会承认康拉德是个帝国主义者，因为他在书中从没有拒绝过帝国主义。他并没有给出，你知道的，他的书本该以人们获得自由或是对奴役他们的帝国主义进行残酷批判而告终。我的意思是，这才是你会得到的。
That is what you get. What? A savage critique? Yes. Well, maybe it's not savage enough for Edward Said and Edward Said is also really disappointed that Conrad doesn't give the Africans a chance of redemption or a chance of escape. And I mentioned in the essay by David Dembe of the New Yorker, he had a little passage in this essay in 1995 imagining saying, well, how would that
这才是你会得到的。什么？残酷的批判？是的。嗯，也许这对于爱德华·萨义德来说还不够残酷，而且爱德华·萨义德也真的感到失望，因为康拉德没有给非洲人哪怕一丝救赎的机会或逃脱的机会。我刚才提到了《纽约客》大卫·丹比的文章，他在1995年的这篇文章中有一小段话，想象着说，那会是怎样一种
work? Like at the end of the book, you know, Kurtz rises from his deathbed and says to an African chief, one day your people will be free and the clouds clear and the sun shines and everybody's singing and dancing. It'd be ridiculous. But that's why Said is a brilliant cultural critic, but he's, you know, he never writes a great work of literature because it would simply be agitprop. Conrad's story is vastly more complex and unsettling than a kind of programmatic response to this would demand.
运作方式呢？比如在书的结尾，你知道的，库尔茨从病榻上起身，对一个非洲酋长说，有一天你们的人民会获得自由，云开雾散，阳光普照，每个人都在载歌载舞。那太荒谬了。但这就是为什么萨义德是一位出色的文化评论家，但他，你知道的，他从未写过伟大的文学作品，因为那只会是宣传煽动。康拉德的故事要远比这种程式化的回应所要求的复杂和令人不安得多。
I totally agree with you about that, Tom, but there's a more substantial critique. Now this is by an African writer called Chinua Achebe. So Nigerian isn't he? Yeah, born in 1930 and in 1975 Achebe gave this lecture at the University of Massachusetts. To people who don't know this will sound like such a trivial and footling thing but this is one of the most influential lectures ever given about kind of about literary culture at all. It's one of the great demolition jobs and it's actually a foundational moment for what's called postcolonial literary studies.
汤姆，关于这一点我完全同意你的看法，但还有一个更实质性的批判。现在，这是一位名叫奇努瓦·阿契贝的非洲作家提出的。所以他是尼日利亚人，对吧？是的，生于1930年，在1975年，阿契贝在马萨诸塞大学发表了这场演讲。对不了解的人来说，这听起来像是一件极其琐碎和微不足道的事，但这是关于文学文化有史以来最有影响力的演讲之一。这是一次伟大的摧毁行动，实际上也是所谓后殖民文学研究的奠基时刻。
And Achebe said, this is, I hate this book, I hate Conrad and I hate this book basically because he just sets up Africa as the heart of darkness. It's the place where Europeans go to find the evil within themselves. You know, you shouldn't, the Conrad's message is keep away from Africa or else, you know, you'll fall victim to the allure of the jungle. The darkness will find you out. You know, you'll become evil if you go to Africa. And he said, and I'm going to quote him, the point of my observation should be
阿契贝说，这是，我讨厌这本书，我讨厌康拉德，我基本上讨厌这本书，因为他只是把非洲设定为黑暗之心。那是欧洲人去寻找内心邪恶的地方。你知道的，你不应该，康拉德的信息是远离非洲，否则，你知道的，你会沦为丛林诱惑的牺牲品。黑暗会找到你。你知道的，如果你去非洲，你就会变坏。他说，我要引用他的话，
quite clear by now, namely that Joseph Conrad was a thorough going racist. And he goes on to say, can a book which dehumanizes Africans, which treats Africa as the heart of darkness, et cetera, et cetera, can it be called a great work of art? My answer is no, it cannot. And this has always been incredibly contentious, this argument among scholars and enthusiasts for Joseph Conrad. You know, is this basically a racist book? And now on college campuses, you will find a lot of people who say it is and either don't teach it or who teach it as an example of literary racism. Now, a lot of people listen to this would
我的观察的重点到现在应该很清楚了，那就是约瑟夫·康拉德是一个彻头彻尾的种族主义者。他接着说，一本将非洲人非人化，将非洲视作黑暗之心等等之类的一本书，能被称为伟大的艺术作品吗？我的回答是，不能，它不能。在学者和约瑟夫·康拉德的爱好者中，这个论点一直极具争议。你知道的，这基本上是一本种族主义的书吗？现在，在大学校园里，你会发现很多人说它是，要么不教它，要么把它作为文学种族主义的例子来教。现在，听到这里很多人会
expect because with the rest of his history that at this point we kind of turn our guns on Chinua and Chaby and say, this is terrible, Konrad's brilliant, blah, blah, blah. Actually, there are elements of his critique, I don't know what you think, Tom, but that I think are justified. So first of all, he does present, the book does present Africa as primeval, as unfathomable, as prehistoric. Going up that river was like traveling back to the earliest beginnings of the world when vegetation rioted on the earth and the big trees were kings.
预料到，因为结合他历史的其余部分，在这个时候我们会把枪口转向奇努瓦·阿契贝，然后说，这太糟糕了，康拉德太棒了，巴拉巴拉。实际上，他的批判中有一些成分——汤姆，我不知道你怎么想——但我认为是有道理的。首先，他确实把非洲呈现为原始的、深不可测的、史前的地方。逆流而上就像是回到了世界的最初起点，当时植被在地球上疯狂生长，大树宛如君王。
Okay, I accept that. However, one of the reasons why it is traveling back to the earliest beginnings of the world is that there are no humans and there are no humans there because they've all been scared off by the depredations of European colonialists. So he's not simply saying, you know, the silent, what is it? He says an empty stream, a great silence. That great silence is expressive of the depredations of European colonists. I agree with you, but you might not know that reading Conrad's book.
好吧，我接受这一点。然而，之所以它是回到世界的最初起点的原因之一，是因为那里没有人类，而那里没有人类是因为他们都被欧洲殖民者的掠夺吓跑了。所以他并不是简单地说，你知道的，那个寂静的，是什么？他说了一条空寂的河流，一片巨大的寂静。那巨大的寂静表达了欧洲殖民者的掠夺。我同意你的看法，但如果你读康拉德的书，你可能不会知道这一点。
Well, he does. He said it. I mean, we just quoted the stuff not know that reading Conrad's book. Well, he does. He said it. I mean, we just quoted the stuff about, you know, the Africans turning up in Kent and launching attacks. Yes, I suppose so. I suppose so. But those two passages are quite far apart and you might not draw the connection. But that is why Conrad is a great writer because he's setting up these, you know, these echoes
嗯，他确实这么做了。他说过。我的意思是，我们刚刚引用了那些……不知道读康拉德的书能知道这一点。嗯，他确实这么做了。他说过。我的意思是，我们刚刚引用了那些关于，你知道的，非洲人出现在肯特并发起进攻的内容。是的，我想是的。我想是的。但这两段内容相距甚远，你可能不会把它们联系起来。但这就是为什么康拉德是一位伟大的作家，因为他在散文中设置了这些，你知道的，那些会产生共鸣的回声。
in the prose that reverberate. Now, the second charge, I think slightly harder to quibble with, I would argue, is that this is a book about Africa that has no serious African characters at all. And when they speak, they don't speak. They chant, they grunt, they make, and I quote, a drone of weird incantations, strings of amazing words that resembled no sounds of human language, like the responses of some satanic litany. And even the physical descriptions that are quite harrowing,
现在，第二个指控，我认为稍微更难反驳，我想说的是，这是一本关于非洲却根本没有严肃的非洲角色的书。当他们说话时，他们不说话。他们吟唱，他们咕哝，他们发出，我引述一下，“一串诡异的咒语声，一连串惊人的词语，听起来不像是人类语言的任何声音，就像某种撒旦连祷文的回应”。甚至那些相当痛苦的物理描述，
they're quite dehumanizing. So the porters that you mentioned, the people who are carrying the stuff on their heads and they're chained together, they had the complete death-like indifference of unhappy savages. Or the railway workers dying in the grove. Black shapes, black shadows of disease and starvation.
它们相当非人化。比如你提到的搬运工，那些把东西顶在头上并被锁在一起的人，他们具有不幸的野蛮人那种完全如死一般的冷漠。或者死在树林里的铁路工人。黑色的人形，疾病和饥饿的黑色阴影。
Would you talk like that about white European characters? I'm not entirely convinced that you would. That I would accept. And we've already touched on Kurtz's African concubine, who is pure stereotyping. Yeah. I mean, the pure kind of fantasy figure. And I think that is where Conrad's kind of literary mastery falls down. Well, I mean, first of all, there's a real complication here, which is that this isn't actually Conrad talking.
你会这样谈论白人欧洲角色吗？我并不完全确信你会。这一点我接受。我们已经谈到了库尔茨的非洲情妇，那纯粹是刻板印象。是的。我的意思是，纯粹的那种幻想人物。我认为这就是康拉德的文学功力失效的地方。嗯，我的意思是，首先，这里有一个真正的复杂之处，那就是这其实不是康拉德在说话。
This is Marlowe talking. Well, yes, yes and no. I mean, because there is a risk that you then start saying anything racist is Marlowe talking. Well, yes, yes and no. I mean, because there is a risk that you then start saying anything racist in it is Marlowe talking. I mean, you can do it either way. I mean, if you start playing that game, depending on what you know, whether you want to, to get Conrad off the charge or not, you can, you can fix the fix your critique. You can, but I think you have to.
这是马洛在说话。嗯，是的，是的 and no。我的意思是，因为存在这样一种风险，即你随后会开始说里面任何种族主义的话都是马洛在说话。嗯，是的，是的 and no。我的意思是，因为存在这样一种风险，即你随后会开始说里面任何种族主义的话都是马洛在说话。我的意思是，你可以双向解读。我的意思是，如果你开始玩这种游戏，取决于你的了解，看你是否想要为康拉德洗脱罪名，你可以，你可以修改你的批判。你可以，但我认为你必须这样做。
So Achibi basically says in his lecture, I'm going to just basically treat Marlow as if he's Conrad, but Marlow isn't Conrad. Conrad is the character listening to Marlow, if Conrad is in the story at all. So I think you just have to be a bit careful by always assuming that an author and their main character are the same person. Well you notice this very, very powerfully when Marlow is coming back and he's puzzling over Kurtz's character and what he represents. You have the sense that Marlow is wrestling all the time.
所以阿契贝在他的演讲中基本上说，我基本上要把马洛当作就是康拉德来对待，但马洛不是康拉德。如果康拉德真的在这个故事里的话，他才是听马洛讲故事的角色。所以我认为，在总是假设作者和他们的主角是同一个人时，你必须有点谨慎。嗯，当马洛回来并对库尔茨的性格以及他所代表的东西感到困惑时，你非常非常强烈地注意到了这一点。你会感觉到马洛一直在挣扎。
He's groping after truth, but there's always a sense that it's kind of slipping his fingers and clearly, you know, he's grasping after the secrets of the human condition, but he is also grasping after the reality and the truth of what is going on in the Belgian Congo. And as we've said, this is written before Morel starts his kind of forensic examination of the details of what has been happening. And you could say that there's an element there of the difficulty that historians have in making sense of what has been happening. And you could say that there's an element there of the difficulty that historians have in making sense of what's been going on. And it is noticeable that we don't have African accounts of what happened.
他在摸索着寻找真理，但总有一种感觉，它仿佛从他的指缝中溜走，显然，你知道的，他在抓取人类生存状态的秘密，但他同时也在抓取比利时刚果正在发生的事情的现实和真相。正如我们所说，这是在莫雷尔开始对所发生事情的细节进行仔细调查之前写成的。你可以说，这里有一种历史学家在理解所发生事情时所面临的困难的成分。你可以说，这里有一种历史学家在理解正在发生的事情时所面临的困难的成分。而且值得注意的是，我们没有关于所发生事情的非洲方面的记载。
I mean, this has been a problem that you've been acknowledging throughout our account, that it really is a story about what Europeans get up to rather than Africans. And I suppose that, you know, Conrad could talk to the Europeans, but he couldn't talk to the Africans. I think that's absolutely right. Now, actually, ultimately, I think this question about is it a racist book or is it not is actually quite a boring one.
我的意思是，这是你在我们的整个叙述中一直在承认的一个问题，即这确实是一个关于欧洲人在搞什么名堂而不是非洲人的故事。我想，你知道的，康拉德可以跟欧洲人对话，但他无法跟非洲人对话。我认为这绝对正确。现在，实际上，归根结底，我认为关于“这是一本种族主义的书还是不是”这个问题其实挺无聊的。
I don't think it's Conrad clearly. I mean, it's such a terribly cliched thing to say. Conrad obviously is a man of his age. He reflects the assumptions that he has grown up with, both in Russian occupied, you know, Eastern Poland and Ukraine, and later on sailing around on British merchant ships. I mean, he's not, you know, he's not outside time. Of course he has prejudices and assumptions of his own and they are expressed in his writing. But the overall effect of this book is obviously not a, I mean it's a book that clearly makes
我不认为这是康拉德。我的意思是，说这种话实在是太陈词滥调了。康拉德显然是个时代的局中人。他反映了他在俄国占领的，你知道的，东波兰和乌克兰成长起来，后来又在英国商船上四处航行时所带有的那些假设。我的意思是，他不是，你知道的，他没有超脱于时代。他当然有他自己的偏见和假设，这些都表现在他的写作中。但这本书的整体效果显然不是一个，我的意思是，这是一本显然能让你
you think really seriously about the moral issues of imperialism and the civilizing mission and colonialism and what not. I mean how can it not? Morel who devoted his entire life to combating Leopold's regime in the Congo said of it that it is the most powerful thing ever written on the subject. Yeah. And I think that is true. And I think that a reigning authors, because they failed to measure up to the ideological standards of 2024, is the least interesting approach to literature that you could possibly
非常认真地思考帝国主义的道德问题、文明使命、殖民主义以及诸如此类事情的书。我的意思是，怎么会不是呢？一生致力于打击利奥波德在刚果政权的莫雷尔曾这样评价它：这是关于这个主题写得最有力量的作品。是的。我认为这是真的。我认为，因为过时的作家未能达到2024年的意识形态标准而对他们进行审判，是你能对文学采取的最不感兴趣的方法。
adopt. Couldn't agree more. I mean, whether or not, of course, Conrad may have been racially prejudiced. I mean, he may mean he may not have been. It's as you say, it's actually, I think, an incredibly boring question because this is a such an interesting book and there's so many more things to say about it. But the possibility that he might be, I think, is woven into the story. I think that might be, you know, the heart of darkness.
不能同意更多了。我的意思是，无论如何，康拉德当然可能存在种族正如你所说，这实际上是一个极其无聊的问题，因为这是一本如此有趣的书，关于它还有那么多话可说。但我认为，他可能存在的这种种族偏见已经交织在故事之中了。我认为那可能就是，你知道的，黑暗之心。
That might be the horror. Conrad, Marlow, whoever it is, is Conrad's voice within the heart of darkness. I mean, all those people, I think, are implicated in what is being discussed. And I think that going beyond that, the lasting appeal of the book is obviously it's about more than the Belgian Congo. It's about more than King Leopold's free state or anything like that. To me, the key line in the book is actually that line that we quoted earlier, right at the beginning before they even got to the Congo, where Marlow says to the people on the boat, and this also has been one of the dark places of the earth.
那可能就是恐怖。康拉德、马洛，无论它是谁，都是黑暗之心内康拉德的声音。我的意思是，我认为所有这些人，都卷入了正在讨论的事情中。我认为除此之外，这本书持久的吸引力显然在于它不仅仅关乎比利时刚果。它不仅仅关乎利奥波德国王的自由邦或诸如此类的事情。对我来说，书中的关键台词其实就是我们之前引用的那句话，就在他们甚至还没到达刚果的最初开始，马洛对船上的人说的那句话：“这地方也是大地的黑暗中心之一。”
And he's talking there about England. He's not talking about the Congo and the darkness is there even before the steamboat has started its journey up the river. I, the darkness is not in the Congo. It's not even in England. It's in humanity. It's the human soul. That's what I think the book's about. And he's riffing there on the tendency.
他那里谈论的是英格兰。他谈的不是刚果，早在汽船开始逆流而上之前，黑暗就已经存在了。我，黑暗不在刚果。它甚至不在英格兰。它在人性中。它在人类的灵魂中。这就是我认为这本书所讲的内容。他在那里对这种倾向进行了演绎。
Well, Stanley is always doing it. Isn't he all his kind of massive volumes, he's always referring to darkest Africa. That is the pivot that London is one of the dark places, that the Thames Estuary was one of the dark places. And of course, dark has all these kind of rich shades of meaning. And it may be that one of those, one of those shades of meaning could be cast as racist, but it is only one of them. And the, the, the, the racism that Europeans display towards Africans is also part of the racism that is being displayed by Romans towards the Britons. Yeah. That this is what imperialists do.
嗯，史坦利总是这样做。难道他所有的那些大部头著作不是都在不断提及“黑暗的非洲”吗？这就是那个支点：伦敦是黑暗的中心之一，泰晤士河口是黑暗的中心之一。当然，黑暗有着所有这些丰富的含义色彩。可能其中一种含义色彩会被打上种族主义的烙印，但这只是其中之一。而且，欧洲人对非洲人表现出的种族主义，也是罗马人对不列颠人表现出的种族主义的一部分。是的。这就是帝国主义者所做的事。
And I don't think it's even that he thinks this is what imperialists do. I think it's what human beings do. I think it's what human beings do. Conrad had a remarkably, I find it very attractive because I share it, a remarkably bleak view of human nature. In his letters to his friend Cunningham Graham, the SMP bloke that we mentioned earlier, he says of mankind, the year before he wrote Heart of Darkness, he wrote to Cunningham Graham, he said, mankind is silly and cowardly, a wretched gang. We're born initiated and succeeding generations clutch the inheritance of fear and brutality without a thought. And another letter, he said, people go on, he said, about honor, justice, compassion, but nobody really believes
我不认为他甚至觉得这是帝国主义者所做的事。我认为这是人类所做的事。我认为这是人类所做事。康拉德对人性有着一种非同寻常的——我发现它非常有吸引力，因为我也有同感——极其黯淡的看法。在他写给朋友坎宁安·格雷姆的信中，也就是我们前面提到的那个SMP（苏格兰民族党）家伙，他在写《黑暗之心》的前一年，在写给坎宁安·格雷姆的信中谈到人类时说，人类是愚蠢而懦弱的，是一群可怜的匪徒。我们生来就被启蒙，而后代们则毫无思考地紧抓着恐惧和野蛮的遗产不放。在另一封信中，他说，人们一直在谈论，他说，荣誉、正义、同情，但没有人真正相信
in them. People believe only in, and I quote, gain personal advantage, satisfied vanity, and words vanish and nothing remains, absolutely nothing, Only a drop of mud, cold mud, dead mud launched in black space, turning round and extinguish sun. I love those lines. Conrad has a view of mankind, of human beings that is unbelievably skeptical, ironic, bleak, dark. Conservative. Yeah.
它们。人们只相信，我引述一下，“利益、个人优势、得到满足的虚荣”，而话语消逝了，什么也没有留下，绝对什么也没有，只有一滴泥浆，冰冷的泥浆，死寂的泥浆，被发射进黑暗的空间，围绕着一颗熄灭的太阳旋转。我太喜欢这些台词了。康拉德对人类、对人性的看法是难以置信地怀疑的、讽刺的、黯淡的、黑暗的。保守的。是的。
Conservative. bleak, dark. Conservative. Yeah, conservative. I mean, he's sceptical about notions of progress and that Jerusalem can be built on the earth. Definitely. But I think the interesting thing about that is it's not just temperamental, but it's of his time. Because I was thinking about the literature of the 1880s, 1890s.
保守的。黯淡的，黑暗的。保守的。是的，保守的。我的意思是，他怀疑进步的概念以及耶路撒冷可以在地球上建成。绝对是的。但我认为关于这一点有趣的是，这不仅仅是性格使然，也是他那个时代特有的。因为我在想1880年代、1890年代的文学。
So in 1890, the year he went to the Congo, um, one of my favorite books, La Betty Humaine by Emily Zola, which is about basically a, I know it sounds very unpromising. It's about a Parisian train driver who turns out to be a sex crazed homicidal maniac. Um, he published this book and it's basically about the evil that is lurking within us all. You know, even the most banal person is actually deep down. You know, we could all be serial killers and rapists and whatnot.
所以在1890年，他去刚果的那一年，嗯，我最喜欢的书之一，埃米尔·左拉的《人的兽性》，它基本上讲的是一个——我知道这听起来很不妙。它讲的是一个巴黎火车司机，结果却是一个性疯狂的杀人狂魔。嗯，他出版了这本书，它基本上是关于潜伏在我们每个人内心的邪恶。你知道的，甚至最平庸的人实际上在内心深处也是如此。你知道的，我们都可能是连环杀手、强奸犯之类的人。
This is such a popular idea in very late Victorian culture. Dracula, which is Dracula, published in 1897. The idea of darkness coming to England. Yeah, absolutely. Or 1899, the same year Conrad publishes Heart of Darkness. That's the year that Freud publishes the interpretation of dreams. The idea that buried deep down in this kind of very primal and unfathomable way, our anxieties and ghosts and terrible urges that we try to repress in our kind
这在维多利亚时代末期的文化中是一个非常受欢迎的想法。《德古拉》，也就是《德古拉》，出版于1897年。黑暗降临英格兰的想法。是的，绝对是。或者在1899年，也就是康拉德出版《黑暗之心》的同一年。那是弗洛伊德出版《梦的解析》的年份。这种想法是，深深埋藏在这种非常原始且深不可测的方式之中的，是我们的焦虑、幽灵和可怕的冲动，我们在那种
of civilized daily lives, but will come always come to claim us at night. I mean, again, all of this sort of stuff is simmering away in the European imagination at the time that Conrad is writing. I mean, there's no question that Heart of Darkness has given to very committed anti-racists, anti-imperialists, some of its language. So there was, I think it was, what was it? Netflix or something. There was a, a documentary series called Exterminate All the Brutes came out three,
文明的日常生活中试图压抑它们，但它们总会在夜里来向我们索命。我的意思是，同样，所有这些东西在康拉德写作时都在欧洲人的想象中酝酿着。我的意思是，毫无疑问，《黑暗之心》为一些坚定的反种族主义者、反帝国主义者提供了一些语言。所以当时有，我想是，那是什么？网飞或其他什么平台。有一部名为《清剿所有野蛮人》的纪录片系列在两、
two or three years ago. And it was about European colonialism and was not favorable at all. Right. And it was based on a book by Sven Linkfist, who is a Norwegian writer who is absolutely excoriating about imperialism, particularly British imperialism. And of course, that title is coming from Kurtz's phrase, which in turn is written by Conrad. And so the echoes are very complex, I think, the kind of the ripples, the reverberations, I think to condemn it as a racist book is harsh.
三年前上映了。它是关于欧洲殖民主义的，一点也不友好。没错。它改编自斯文·林德qvist的一本书，他是一位挪威作家，对帝国主义、尤其是英国帝国主义进行了极其严厉的痛斥。当然，这个书名来自库尔茨的那句话，而这句话反过来又是康拉德写的。所以，我认为这些回音非常复杂，那种涟漪，那种共鸣，我认为谴责它是一本种族主义的书是严厉的。
I think, I think it's not just harsh. I think it's a total waste of time. I think it's a complete and utter waste of time when the book is so rich and we've talked for too long and actually we shouldn't. We're not in the business of preaching to listeners. Listeners can make up their own minds. They should read the book. If you think it's racist, great crack on.
我认为，我认为这不仅仅是严厉。我认为这是完全浪费时间。当这本书如此丰富，而我们已经聊了太久，实际上我们不应该这样时，我认为这完全是彻底的浪费时间。我们不是在向听众说教。听众可以自己做决定。他们应该读这本书。如果你觉得它是种族主义的，好极了，尽管读。
If you don't brilliant. Um, Tom, why don't we end with the end of the book? Okay. Marlow ceased and sat apart in distinct and silent in the pose of a meditating Buddha. Nobody moved for a time. We've lost the first of the Ebb said the director suddenly. I raised my head. The offing was barred by a black bank of clouds, and the tranquil waterway leading to the uttermost
如果你不觉得，太棒了。嗯，汤姆，我们为什么不以这本书的结尾来结束呢？好吧。马洛停了下来，独自坐在一边，轮廓分明而又沉默不语，摆出一副沉思的佛陀姿态。有一会儿谁也没有动。导演突然说：“我们错过了第一次退潮。”我抬起头。远处的出口被一排黑色的云层挡住，通往地球最遥远
ends of the earth flowed somber under an overcast sky, seemed to lead into the heart of an immense darkness. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
角落的平静水道在阴沉的天空下显得阴暗，似乎通往一个巨大黑暗的心脏。再见。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。